this is jocko podcast number 302
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
sir we have a tech
as i quickly walked across our tactical
operation center to the opera to radio
operator i'm sure my heart rate spiked
a tick pronounced tick stands for troops
in contact
it is something arresting everyone's
attention because it meant one of our
patrols was taking enemy fire on the
mean streets of ramadi
as i pressed the handset of the radio to
my ear
i could hear a sense of urgency in the
voice of the patrol leader on the ground
he was leading a group of soldiers on a
dismounted patrol on ramadi's
southwestern side of town
things could get kind of sporty there
the young sergeant leading the patrol
was requesting a direct super cobra
gunship helicopters to fire at
insurgents
on top of a building
they were engaged by insurgents with
small arms from behind a building but
now he could see guns and other weapons
on the roof
the insurgent had ceased for the moment
but the patrol leader was concerned
about what might come next
something did not feel right
people need to pay attention to gut
feelings and instinct
i have found the more experience one
gains the more gut feeling factors into
decision making
if something does not feel right it
probably requires a little more
attention
i used a steady voice to calm the patrol
leader down
i let him know i would call in the
cobras
but first i needed him to provide
positive identic identification of
exactly who was on top of that building
my intuition was telling me to let the
situation develop before calling in
heavy firepower
after a few minutes the patrol leader
made a positive identification of the
force on the rooftop on the rooftop
i was glad i did not pull the trigger on
the cobras
a u.s marine corps civil affairs team
were on the top of the building
a stressful situation was averted
calmness and coolness prevailed
as it turned out the small arms fire he
received was some harassment fire and
the insurgents who initiated the
incident had quickly disappeared
so that right there is an
excerpt from a book
which is called iron sharpened
leadership which was written by
general john gronski
who served in the us army and the
national guard for over
40 years and i had the honor of serving
with him during the battle of ramadi
where our deployments
overlapped by about a month or so in the
spring of 2006
and he's actually been on the podcast
before episode 235 so if you haven't
listened to that podcast yet
stop
and go and listen to that one to get
some background on general gronsky but
we are honored to have general gronsky
back again tonight
to discuss his new book
which as i said is called iron sharpened
leadership and the subtitle is
transforming hard-fought lessons into
action
so general gronsky
once again thank you for coming by hey
jocko it's great to be with you thanks
for inviting me always good to be uh
here in san diego san diego's not a bad
place to be
uh
so
your first book
that we did we touched upon on the last
podcast it was called the ride of our
lives and it was about a bike rate bike
ride that you
made across
america with your wife
and your infant child
and you talked about some of the lessons
that you learned
along that voyage
and the experience you had but that was
very early in your army career
and this is
reflective of your entire army career so
what what made you decide to write this
book iron sharpened leadership yeah you
know jaco when i wrote that book the
right of our lives uh near the end of
the book i put some um just leadership
lessons that i gained on that ride as
you mentioned
and i actually had people uh asking me
to expand on those lessons and you know
the book focused just on that very short
period of time three months in 1983
and i i just uh
gained so much more experience and
learned so many more lessons over the
next 30 plus years
and i just felt compelled to to put
those lessons down in the writing and
hopefully
would help other people gain from really
most of the mistakes i made along the
way
did had you written the ride of our
lives
in close proximity when it actually took
place or was that did you remember back
30 years or whatever it was yeah you
know
going i took that bike ride with my wife
and 15 month old son back in 1983 i kept
the journal got it that journal sat in a
shoe box for
over 35 years and then when i retired
from the army in 2019
had a little bit of time on my hand so i
decided to
you know write the book the right of our
lives and it was really
meant to be for for myself to reflect
back on and for my family to have
and then i decided to self-publish it as
as a book and uh it turned out to be
quite popular
awesome so
so this book like you said this is this
is going back on your whole career and
the lessons that you've learned and you
you've been through the
entire leadership spectrum in in the
army
and spent a bunch of time in combat
and so this is a great book and uh let's
jump into it
so and then just so everybody knows look
if
i have to skip around i'm not going to
read the whole book right now
there is an audiobook version of this as
well but we're not going to read the
whole thing so i'm going to jump into
some spots it's it's obviously not going
to be completely cohesive when we read
it on the podcast it's it's set up in a
very cohesive manner in the way it's
read but i gotta make that uh caveat
before i start reading but here's the
one i wanted to start with go into the
book some of the best leadership advice
was given to me by a crusty
non-commissioned officer during my first
experience in the army when i was
training as an rotc cadet at fort knox
kentucky in 1976.
i was a patrol leader during a training
event in the scenario my patrol was
passing through a cleared lane within a
minefield
the lane was about 40 yards in length as
we began
as we were crossing them the minefield
on the cleared lane we began to receive
small arms fire from an enemy position
about 200 yards away
i hesitated
the soldiers were waiting for a command
i did not give
it took less than a minute for the enemy
to destroy my entire patrol
the sergeant who was a seasoned vietnam
veteran pulled me aside and loudly
advised
when in charge
be in charge
your followers expect you to lead so you
better damn well lead
good lesson learned out of the gate yeah
again
i could just say as i reflect back on my
career it was those non-commissioned
officers
especially uh early on in my career
those vietnam vets uh who i was
fortunate to be around and fortunate to
get you know just just some hard advice
from you know no no punches pulled hey
this is the way it should be
you know so square yourself away
and lead when you're in a leadership
position
yeah you know i was thinking in that
particular case and
when i was running training a lot of
times
the the younger guys the young seal
officers
one thing that would happen to them
would be
there would be a a platoon chief or a
leading petty officer that would get in
the habit of making a lot of the calls
and so the officer would get in the
habit of not making calls
and it was a
it wasn't even a fine line what they had
to realize was
if uh if one of the ncos makes a call
awesome you help them you support their
call you're gonna go no factor all good
it's in those moments those rare moments
where you know in this particular case
maybe the nco got hit with the first
volley of fire or the ncl was in a
position on the minefield where he could
see where the fire was coming from so
they can't make a call
or they're panicked or whatever the case
may be so you get that leadership vacuum
and that's when
that officer has to be detached enough
has to be heads up enough to go oh wait
a second my ncos aren't making a call i
need the lead right now
so it's a little bit of a cautionary
tale too
you know if when you're in charge that
doesn't necessarily mean you need to
make the call but you better be prepared
in case
you know the the people that you're
subordinate leadership doesn't make
something happen in an ideal world
subordinate leadership makes a call you
don't have to do anything
i hate to say it but in an ideal world
when you're in charge you don't have to
do anything
yeah i ideally and you know jackie you
speak to the fact that
you know you have to put
your followers into positions where they
have that opportunity to make some of
those tough calls and you know i even
think of this uh reflecting back you
know my kids are both in their 30s now
but reflecting back
when when my children were teenagers
and i really think it's important for
parents to let young teenagers make
decisions because if parents are making
all the decisions for their kids when
are they going to learn how to make a
decision you know they're going to learn
learn how to make a decision when they
become an adult well that's kind of too
late
uh so i i do think you need to to put
your followers in positions where they
they gain that experience hey and if
they make a mistake
you know that's usually how we learn
more is when we make a mistake when than
when we do something
right by accident yeah that's uh i was
gonna say when you were saying let your
kids make decisions let your kids make
mistakes too and just like in the
military this doesn't mean you're gonna
send a young you know first lieutenant
out on an operation that they're not
capable of conducting because they don't
have the experience yet they don't have
the knowledge you're not gonna say oh
let's see how it goes no you're not
gonna do that just like you're not gonna
say oh my kid wants to go play in the
street which is not a good decision
where they could get hit by a card and
that's not what we're talking about
but you can certainly let them make
decisions and let them brush up against
the guardrails of failure because that's
where you learn through those little
scratches that you get on the on the
body
exactly
i'mma fast forward a little bit
um because this this section kind of
sets up the rest of the book my personal
leadership philosophy is based on three
elements of character competence and
resilience
there are sub components to each element
of my leadership philosophy
character competence resilience and
their subcomponents are skills
and like any other skill they can be
learned and strengthened although some
may be born with higher levels of any
one of these elements everyone can
improve them through training and
practice
and this is something that
i think there's a lot of people in the
world
that think that leadership
is something you're born with and either
you have it or you don't and like you
said there are certainly
you might have some advantages in some
areas you might be pretty
articulate you might be pretty
you know visionary you might be have a
good sense of other people's emotions
there's different
levels that people have in all those
categories
but no matter where you are in all these
categories you can improve upon them
then you can get better and i think a
lot of people think oh leadership is
just
just going to come through osmosis or
it's something you're born with and
there's nothing you can do to actually
train it when the fact of the matter is
there's a hundred percent things that
you can do to improve your leadership
skills
yeah and uh you know i think it's
like athleticism you know some people
are are born with better athletic skills
than others but everybody could improve
in that athleticism it doesn't mean
everybody's going to be a
you know an nfl player or nba player
whatever
but everybody could get better and i
feel the same way about leadership and
and that's another reason why i wrote
the book and just as you've written many
leadership books to to try to
help people develop those skills that we
know could be improved yeah yeah and
that's the benefit of being in the
military is you get to see
over and over again young leaders
actually improve and get better and and
make better decisions and get more
experience so it's something that you
and i through the blessing of being in
the military got to see over and over
again it's it's fact it's a fact that
you know leaders can be improved
um let me get into these these
components here the first one character
character is the root of leadership a
leader of character will be able to
establish an environment of trust a
character-based leader grows trust by
trusting others first
providing a vision displaying integrity
leading by example and sincerely caring
about others
a leader must have values and principles
values are something a person believes
in and will be guided by when times are
good and when times are tough
a character-based leader sincerely cares
about those they lead
and they place the interests of their
followers above their own
the key component
i had a guy on this podcast by the name
of general james mukayama
and he was
he served in vietnam
and he worked for
he worked for colonel david hackworth
when hackworth was the battalion
commander mukuyamo was one of his
company commanders but that was a point
that he made so clear was that idea of
you got to care about your people and
that was a thing that hackworth had that
i don't know if it always comes about or
comes across in in his books and in his
writings but
hackworth just cared about his soldiers
and that elevated him so much in their
eyes and that's exactly what you're
talking about here yeah and um
you know
it's it's easy to say you know uh care
about your your people that you lead but
it's
i think extremely hard to do
to put the interest of those you lead
before your own interest i think the
only people who could naturally do that
are parents you know i think parents
could naturally
put the interests of their their kids
before their own
but to do that to uh people that you
know aren't aren't blood relatives of
yours that that that's a hard
thing to do and i've been fortunate
enough to be around uh leaders in the
military who have that ability to do
that was almost an innate sense they had
to put the welfare
of those they lead first and you know we
learned this in in the army and the
marines and the navy air force you know
that uh you know leaders eat last and
and the reason we do that you know you
could imagine you know you're out there
either in a training environment
uh or on an operation you get this ciao
mermaided outy in the field
and you know it's rainy it's cold and if
that leader jumps into child line first
there's probably whoever is going to be
the last guy in the child line probably
isn't going to eat or at least get a
full portion i mean that's why leaders
eat last you want your
folks that you lead that have the
benefit of of that nutrition before
before you suck
suck it down you know
and again we we learned this in the
military and i think
you know uh folks in the civilian sector
uh some
some know that kind of
innately and others uh maybe never
experienced that and that's why i think
there's some organizations
uh that cannot develop that le that that
trust that is so essential if you're
going to have an organization
effectively run
another thing about this is i think
there's people
who
think that they can fool their troops
and
their subordinate leadership into
thinking that they care about them and
and i promise you having been
a young enlisted guy having been the
youngest and most junior guy in my first
two seal platoons
everybody can tell when you're looking
out for yourself everybody can tell
you're not fooling anyone and that's why
the people that truly care about the the
team and put the team above themselves
that's why they always shine yeah yeah
and uh you know you think of examples
that we've seen in the military you know
uh
uh a a leader who i remember when i was
over in ramadi you know one one of the
platoons was getting some better version
of an up armored humvee
and the platoon leader refused to take
that better version he made sure you
know this his other soldiers in in the
platoon got that version before he would
take it to to ride in himself and that's
putting yourself more at risk for the
benefit of those you lead so there's a
perfect example of how one could do that
especially if it means putting your life
at risk uh that this guy was a true
leader 100 no that's that's a
outstanding example right there
next thing next characteristic
competence when i talk about competence
being an element of leadership i am not
referring to the technical confidence in
a specific job i am referring to the
general competence of a person to lead
others
many elements make up competence
but the most imperative
are providing a vision and purpose for
the organization decision making
developing others and communication a
leader must be able to articulate a
vision which is simple unique ideal
image of the future
leaders must explain the why behind the
vision and tell their followers what
they believe in
when leaders provide
vision and purpose they instill
confidence and provide inspiration that
fuels an organization empowering it to
success
a leader must learn and apply
problem-solving skills and
decision-making processes
a leader also must possess the courage
to decide one of the most important
roles of a leader is to develop other
leaders a leader must mentor and coach
must be a mentor and coach willing to
take others assigned and provide insight
into what it means to be a leader a
leader must communicate in clear concise
and respectful manner most leaders spend
between 70 and 90 of their time
communicating it is important for a
leader to develop listening skills and
the ability to get a consistent message
out to all stakeholders
so that's the the competency of being a
leader all these skills that you list in
here and again what's interesting about
these skills is
you know if you scan through them
can you get better at
[Music]
explaining the vision yes you can can
you get better at decision making yes
you can can you get better at problem
solving yes you can can you get better
at decision making yes you can can you
get better at mentoring yes you can
every one of these can you get better at
communicating in simple clear concise
language respectful manner yes you can
everything you're talking about here
with the competence of a leader
is is something that you can you can
improve upon yeah and uh you know in in
the book as people go through it they'll
see
you know there's stories associated with
these lessons that i've learned
and then there's certain actions i i
found uh through my experience over the
last 40 years that uh help one
get better and stronger at these
particular skills that you mentioned
yeah so just to make that clear because
i don't know how much i did in my notes
but you you broke the book down almost
like a military learning manual where
hey here's the actions that you need to
take if you want to improve in these
areas and i know i don't hit them i
think i hit a couple of them but that's
what that's the way the book is broken
down
um
the last thing is resilience
anyone who has ever led anything will
tell you that at some point in time the
organization you lead will face
adversity for that matter every living
person faces adversity at some point in
their lives it all comes down to
how prepared one is to face these
challenges and how one responds
leaders must prepare themselves and give
their followers
and their followers to overcome
challenges positive energy is essential
when leading a large organization or a
small team optimism and enthusiasm are
two key traits of a resilient person
like any other trait they must be
exercised to become a strong
part of one's makeup
a leader must be physically emotionally
mentally and spiritually fit
to strengthen resilience leaders must
follow themselves must allow themselves
to be vulnerable by moving out of their
comfort zone by taking risks and taking
on tough challenges scar tissue is
developed and resilience is improved
so the person that's going to lead had
better be able to be able to get back up
again if they get knocked down yeah and
you know jaco i think resilience is
something that has been talked about a
lot a lot over the last few years
but resilience
i don't i don't believe resilience
actually just happens by itself
uh you know you've got to train to
become a resilient person by doing
certain things that that you just
mentioned you know
moving out of your comfort zone i mean
if if you're a leader or a person who
just wants to take the
uh easy way of just staying in your
comfort zone doing things that you know
how to do never stretching yourself
never putting yourself in a position
where you might make a mistake because
you think you're going to look bad in
front of your followers or your peers or
whomever
you're not going to grow that way and
and then when tough times do happen
you're going to be less likely to
demonstrate the resiliency that's needed
in order to
help your organization get through those
tough times
reminds me talking to some of the
some of the tankers actually this was
the one one ad that replaced you guys in
ramadi but one thing that i found
interesting was so they do
the and and it was actually a guy named
mike bahima who is the was a company
commander fantastic guy but he was
explaining to me what what they do to
prepare for deployment one of the things
that they do to prepare for deployment
is they bring their tank on this tank
range and they do gunnery where you're
shooting and you're moving and
maneuvering the tank and doing comms and
reloading
and
it's a challenge it's like uh i i guess
in for an infantry guy for or for a seal
it's like doing a combat conditioning
course where you run you shoot you got
head plates to hit you got long distance
shots to take you got to do pull-ups and
rope climbs and you got to shoot more
it's like that but it's in a tank
and one thing that he said to me was
when they go do gunnery
the first person that goes is battalion
commander exactly that sets the example
hey this i'm going first and so what
you're talking about getting out of your
comfort zone i can't imagine a lot of
those tanker those tank battalion
commanders
they've probably been out of the tank
for a while and yet they're going to
step up and they're going to show okay
this is it this is what we do yeah and
um
you know you kind of reminded me of of
something that i wouldn't mind sharing
with you because i i think it's it's uh
kind of a great lesson in in resiliency
and and this goes back to ramadi um i
had a uh a national you know one of our
national guard tank companies
when we were training it at uh camp
shelby before going over to to iraq
uh
this this company has three platoons and
one of their platoons went through that
tank gunnery that that you just talked
about only one of their platoons did
uh and when they got over to ramadi we
actually
task organized them to 269 armor which
was an easter mighty combat outpost
corrigador area
and since 269 armor was was an armored
battalion they didn't need
this company to
operate in tanks so they made the
motorized infantry so they operated as
motorized infantry for the six the first
six months they were over in ramadi
and then two six nine armor leaves and
they get replaced by first of the 506
infantry from the 101st airborne
light infantry
but tanks were still needed in easter
madi so now these
these national guard soldiers who were
tankers operating as motorized infantry
for the previous six months
are now in tanks
and they just did a remarkable job
they had several
main
gun engagements while they were over
there
and
it just goes to show you how by training
to be resilient and training in those
skills
even when you're taken out of that
particular job in a combat situation for
six months and then having to go back
into those tanks again and then just
performing remarkably
i think is just just a great story of
not only resiliency but but adaptability
yeah i think that's something that has
made the seal team successful
and it starts in the basic seal training
and i always say that hey you know the
basic skill training you don't really
learn anything because you're just doing
push-ups and being wet cold and
miserable you learn how to suffer and if
you don't like to suffer you're not
going to be there
but one thing i will say is you're
getting total chaos like it's total
chaos when you're there you
everything that happens i mean you go
out you go out your boats in the ocean
and they're getting flipped over and
you're getting washed up on and people
are confused lost you got chem lights
bouncing all over the place
you know when hell week kicks off
there's just total chaos confusion
there's they're throwing smoke grenades
everywhere you can't see anything
there's machine guns going off you can't
hear anything and it's just like that
all the time so you get used to this
environment where there's total chaos
going on and you have to figure it out
you have to adapt and then when i got to
the steel teams and it's not so much
like this anymore but it still does have
this
still does have this this dna which is
there there was no doctrine when i got
the seal teams
if you want to do a raid if someone
didn't tell you if your platoon chief
didn't know how to do a raid you had to
just figure it out and there's good and
bad to that i mean it's kind of good in
the army you want to do a raid you can
pick up the what is it seven tac six
infantry platoon and squad you can
figure out how to do raid it tells
everybody what they need to do seal
teams doesn't have that and so you just
go okay well what makes sense how can we
do this
and and like i said there's some good to
that there's some bad to that because
now you might not come up with the best
plan but there's also some good because
you're constantly learning to adapt and
and i think that's one of the things and
it's look the whole i'm i'm saying that
about the seal teams because that's my
environment but the military in general
does that and that's exactly what you're
talking about you take guys you train
them
in one
in one aspect of combat you take them on
deployment you put them into a totally
different aspect of combat they perform
and then halfway through you switch them
back to the original thing and they get
back on that horse and do it again or in
this case get back in those tanks yeah
and do it again yeah
and uh
you know i remember when we got over
when the brigade uh
i was part of got over to
to ramadi in 2005
coin doctrine wasn't written yet
and uh you know coin doctrine wasn't uh
written by uh general petraeus and
general mattis until early 2006 really
and uh so
there was no coin academy that you know
leader that leaders from my brigade went
to when we got to iraq but i think 2006
2007 after that any brigade that got
uh deployed iraq went through this thing
called the the coin academy
the counterinsurgency academy and so we
we kind of had to figure it out on our
own and the way you figure it out you
know you read history
uh you see how it was done in the past
you just use some common sense
you talk to uh leaders that that you
respect and they that you count on and
you kind of figure it out and
that was the interesting thing that was
done there you know a brigade of 5 000
soldiers and marines but a lot of the
operations were occur occurring at the
platoon and company level so it's not
like you know because i was a brigade
commander i was directing some type of
large brigade operation that didn't
exist they were all done at very small
unit levels and
and uh just just an amazing thing about
our american
you know uh uh servicemen
and women uh they figure it out they
have a way to figure it out and i think
uh if you read history of the military
which i know
you you do when you read on on your
podcast regularly
uh it's just amazing how we have uh you
know how our american
uh military has just figured things out
as we went yeah i don't even remember
because
the first
went up so i arrived in ramadi in like
april of 2006.
i visited one of my friends who was an
intel officer
at one of the at one of the bases
and
in ramadi
and she had the big targeting board
and i had worked with her before
she had that big targeting board when i
was in iraq before the same big
targeting board i was like man this is
this is not a good sign because if we're
just going to be targeting these people
and this is this board is just as big as
as it was when i left yeah
and i went back to my talk my tackle
operation center and i googled i think i
must have heard something about this new
counter insurgency manual but i googled
it and it was on it was a draft copy
because it didn't even get released yet
it was a draft copy that i got and i was
just like okay this is it and i found it
on i forget those websites those uh
there's a couple websites
i want to say one of them was like
globalsecurity.org maybe i found out but
i was on one of those websites that i
used to read about what was happening in
the world sort of from a from a military
geopolitical perspective
also has a bunch of manuals so it had
the new fm three tac 24 counter
insurgency and i i i literally read it
that like that night day it's pretty
long and i just plucked things from it
yeah and realized okay this is what we
need to do and i remember i know i i
stole from it because i remember my boss
saying you know what what's your
objective in these types of operations
and i said provide security for the
populace which i know i didn't make that
up on my own i didn't come up with that
that's 100 stolen from uh from the the
insurgency manual
and and that's what that's what kind of
drove me in that direction of like hey
how can we really help
the broader conventional forces that are
here as as they start to move in and and
try and stabilize what's happening yeah
you know it's it's it's funny you
mentioned that because we we kind of uh
evolved and and i read somewhere or
somebody told me you know you can't kill
yourself out of an insurgency
and we when we first got there you know
our our mission was to
you know kill the insurgents
and we evolved into protecting the
populace because we realized you know
the the main
the main uh
goal here is to protect the populace in
order to
change chaos into into something that
was going to be calmer than chaos there
and so uh
the same type of thinking you had about
your your mission of protecting the the
people of ramadi we we kind of evolved
into that too from
uh again reading history
uh
talking to some of the uh
iraqi leaders in ramadi that we would be
dealing with on a regular basis and and
we came to the conclusion that hey if
we're going to be successful here it's
about protecting the population not not
not simply killing the bad guys now
sometimes you would have to kill bad
guys in order to protect the populace so
i'm not saying you know that was totally
off the table uh but
the mindset completely changed for us
throughout that one year that we
conducted operations there
yeah
awesome stuff um
getting back to the book here
um you say discipline respect and
selflessness are part of the united
states army's dna forged over 200 years
ago during the training of the
continental army at valley forge
pennsylvania
you throw in pennsylvania any chance you
get can't don't you i got to yeah
these traits have served our military
well and account at least in part for
the reason the united states military
always tops polls announcing the most
trusted organizations in america any
leader would do well to demonstrate the
traits
of self-discipline respect for others
and selflessness in order to lead
effectively
now you got a story in here
about
uh was it sergeant mike catcher mike
hutch kocher
tell us that story yeah uh mike is uh
an amazing uh person
mike kacher was a soldier in the
pennsylvania national guard 28th
infantry division
uh who uh
was deployed to afghanistan
and while he was in afghanistan a rocket
came in
this rocket
landed about
10 feet away from him
and it just caused significant wounds to
my catcher
broke his jaw
uh you know internal
bleeding and and damages
and then his his his left arm was
wounded so signific significantly that
it had to be
amputated and they you know as they were
treating him he was eventually put in a
in a in a coma in an induced coma and it
took him two years to recover from these
very very
significant wounds that he had
and you know he had a lot to deal with
obviously recovering from these wounds
not
you know losing his arm etc etc
and he decided that the way he was going
to overcome
this adversity
that he was facing
was to
just build himself up physically and
compete in physical competition and so
he decided to enter the invictus games
and uh the invictus games uh uh were
created i think by
prince harry if i'm not mistaken
and it was all about bringing you know
wounded warriors together to compete in
olympic-style competition
and so i i believe it was in 2018 in in
sydney australia when mike was competing
in his third invictus game
as he was competing in some track and
field events he noticed this young girl
about eight years old in the stands and
she was kind of
you know shadowing him whatever event he
would go to compete in she would kind of
you know move her seat and come over and
watch him and then he he realized she
had one arm
and um
when it came time for him to receive his
silver medal that he earned
he asked gemma to come up on the podium
with him and when he was given the
silver medal he took it from around his
neck and put it around gemma's neck and
gifted
the silver medal that he worked so hard
for to this young
eight-year-old australian girl and i had
the opportunity to uh
email back and forth with gemma's father
who again is australian
and he went on to tell me how that had
just completely changed gemma's life
another interesting thing he told me
he said you know gemma's arm was not
amputated she was born without that arm
and he said and there's a psychological
difference between having your arm
amputated or being born without an arm
so he made that distinction
clear to me
and he went on to say that you know from
mike doing that what mike probably
thought was a very simple
gesture
it just dramatically changed jim gemma's
life and now she's competing in sports
as a matter of fact i see
pictures of her on instagram where she's
winning swim meets
and uh she's just ready to to tear it up
because of this very simple
leadership gesture that that mike kocher
demonstrated to her
and it go it just goes to show you that
the the simple things we do in life as
leaders
have a profound effect
on on those that we do those things for
and uh you know you call it similar to
the butterfly effect
you know that uh you know this this this
could have a generational impact i don't
want to sound true too dramatic here but
it could it could have a generational
impact on gemma and on gemma's children
if she has children someday etc etc uh
just because of that very selfless act
that that mike carter did and you got to
realize you know you work hard to get
the silver medal
you know
i mean just to give it away like that to
somebody that you don't really know
uh was was quite a gesture so uh that
that's that's the story about mike yeah
i can only imagine a a young girl like
that and you know young girls and boys
but i would i've got three daughters and
one son and i would say that girls are
really self-conscious about you know
those kind of things
their body their they're self-conscious
about that and you could imagine someone
like gemma who's sort of avoiding any
time where all of a sudden this becomes
the focus is like
what's different about her
and and him just coming along and saying
yeah it's cool yeah it's good yeah don't
worry about it go do your thing exactly
and how much that just changed your life
that's awesome to hear yeah yeah
um you wrap up this uh idea here you say
self-discipline
giving up could become a habit working
hard and striving continually to get
better is also habit habits are
developed through repetition and where
self-discipline comes in leaders who are
self-disciplined adhere to the same
standards they have set for their
followers
they lead by example and share hardship
struggles and tough jobs with their
followers by the way adhering to the
same standards you expect from others
and sharing the load are two of several
actions a leader must take to instill
trust throughout an organization
self-disciplined people have the
motivation to do the hard work behind
the scenes which makes them great at
what they do these people have the drive
to act in order to make themselves
better and to avoid anything detrimental
to achieving their goals this work ethic
generally has a way of making everyone
around them better too
self-disciplined leaders have a bias for
action and in uncertain times
leaders dispel uncertainty through
competent and confident actions
self-discipline leaders have an
offensive mindset and do not allow
setbacks or obstacles to stop progress
good leaders find a way to win and
inspire faith and belief throughout an
organization some people are born with a
greater propensity to be
self-disciplined than others like other
traits self-discipline can be developed
for those who have poor self-discipline
i have found the best way to improve
self-discipline is to do some small
things and work yourself into a more
difficult things if you hit a bump and
backslide a bit do not beat yourself up
just get back with the program remember
good habits are developed through
self-discipline of continuing to do
those
things i get asked this question a
decent amount
um
am i disciplined because i was in the
navy or am i disciplined because i am
disciplined
and i don't know what do you think
i think i think the training that you
received in the navy certainly certainly
helped is my belief um
and and i think
goals are important you know i mean if
if if you have no goals in your life
nothing
that's meaningful and purposeful for you
to work toward what the hell are you
going to be disciplined about you know i
mean you're going to be kind of like
just just drifting one way or the other
so i think uh
you know people that have specific goals
you know your goal to be a seal your
goal once you were a seal to you know be
a seal commander etc etc
kind of sets you up to
be more disciplined about achieving
those goals so
uh i i think it's probably a little bit
of of both
uh but i do think the path you chose and
those goals you had
probably did a lot to help you become a
very self-disciplined person and you
think that's the same for you then
well um i do i i think if i didn't take
the path i i did by by getting into the
army
uh i probably wouldn't have had the
benefit of those ncos and and other role
models who showed me that in order to
achieve something you really got to work
hard for now yeah when i was growing up
as a kid you know my dad my family tried
to show me those things
uh so i i think it's
you know now that i'm thinking of it
it's it's kind of i think uh
building blocks along the way in your
life you know you're going to learn some
of that from your family and then you
know i'm a big believer in sports you
know you play sports like you know i
played some sports in high school and
you have to be disciplined in order to
get out there on a field and not get
yourself beat up right
uh and and then you know you you join
the military and again you've got to
show some discipline in order to because
you know people are counting on you in
in in order to achieve what what you
want to in that regard so i think it's
really like a building block as you go
through your life and some people are
fortunate to have
role models and and and mentors in their
life who are going to show them why
discipline is important and then you
just continue with it
yeah i think i was i don't know if this
is lucky or unlucky i was lucky in the
fact that i wasn't really great at
anything and when i got to the seal
teams if i didn't work hard i was going
to look like an idiot and i didn't want
to let my teammates down so i had to
just work hard to be ready for stuff
that's definitely the that definitely
influenced my path quite a bit i think
if i would have been a natural a
naturally gifted athlete
i would i probably would
have
had less discipline i would have needed
as much discipline
but but the other thing you gotta
remember is people get out of the seal
teams and sometimes they're even still
in the steel teams and they you know
they let themselves go they don't
practice they don't train they get out
of shape yeah um
you know it's so just because you were
in the military just because you were
in the seal teams or whatever you did
and you got to maintain that discipline
that discipline is not it's not a chip
that they put into your brain and now
you got it you don't have to worry about
it anymore no
no you still got to go yeah you know
jack and i i do think that's why purpose
is so important and those goals are so
important because the same at ranger
school you know
uh you know you get you get that ranger
tab and that's when the hard work should
start because now you've got to prove it
every day that i i deserve to have this
ranger tab on my shoulder and i and i
see it
uh you know folks i know that that went
to ranger school and now they're out of
the military and they kind of just like
let themselves go and and it's probably
because they don't have that that
purpose anymore or that goal anymore and
uh
i i think that's an unfortunate thing
and that's why purpose is so important
that's why i think leaders have to
uh be able to communicate purpose to
their followers so their followers
understand and i know you talk about
this in your dichotomy of leadership
book you know so so people understand
why am i doing this thing that the
leader has told me to do well if you
don't explain the purpose the leaders
are the the followers aren't going to
get it yeah 100
yeah
um
fast forward a little bit dignity and
respect leaders demonstrate leaders
demonstrate respect for others by the
words they choose the tone of voice they
use and by treating people with dignity
demonstrating respect is also about
being considered of a person's time and
showing interest in what others think
good leaders treat others respectfully
regardless of position good leaders
treat the maintenance
person with the same amount of respect
they treat the ceo
i believe it is impossible to be toxic
leader to be a toxic leader if you treat
those people you lead with dignity and
respect this does not mean you cannot
hold people to the prescribed standard
and counsel them however there is a
dignified and respectful way to do those
things a leader could even fire someone
in a dignified and respectful way a rule
to follow is praise in public reprimand
and private now
what's interesting about this paragraph
is this is
anybody that doesn't that has sort of a
surface view of the military they don't
think that this is they don't think this
is applicable at all in the military i
guess it's just from boot camp movies
right yeah i guess it's just from full
metal jacket
full metal jacket has
has given and i love that movie it's a
great movie it's an it's an incredible
movie and it is accurate you know you
talk to any marine look they don't use
the same language that they used back
then but man boot camp is boot camp and
it is yelling and screaming making
people uncomfortable and and really
not treating them but treating them with
disrespect especially in the beginning
so i think movies like that
have given this
false image of the military that that's
how military leadership works and it
and it is not true now are there leaders
that act like that yeah there are
absolutely are in the military and guess
what there's leaders that act like that
in the civilian sector too that act that
are disrespectful that treat people bad
they're in leadership positions and and
it's not good it is not good and and
what's interesting about this is
i can yell and scream if i if i'm your
boss i can yell at screaming you and
you're probably gonna do what i tell you
you're intimidated you don't want to get
fired you
you don't want to hear me yell and
scream so you go do what i told you to
do and so i get some positive feedback
on my yelling and screaming
however as soon as you get home you're
on monster.com looking for a new job
because you don't want to be working
with me because i'm a jerk right and by
the way how much effort do you actually
give you know do you give 110 no you
probably give
72 which is the bare minimum you needed
to give to get the job done so all my
yelling and screaming got me the bare
minimum that you're gonna produce
whereas if i treated you with respect
you're gonna give 110 you're gonna do
that job better than
i could do it and better than you could
do it with your minimum effort so this
idea
treating people with respect i mean this
is just
it seems like common sense and i think
sometimes i mean i had this happen when
i when i started working with companies
the very f actually was one i wasn't the
very first it was one of the first
companies i started working with and i'm
on the phone with the ceo doing an
introductory call and he says i can't
wait till you get out here and whip my
people into shape
and i said hey you know something if you
want someone to whip your people into
shape you should get someone else
because whipping people is what happens
that's what you do to slaves and slaves
is not a good environment and no one
wants to be a slave and they don't do
the job that they're supposed to do
they'll do the bare minimum so they
don't get
punished for it
so i'm glad you got this section in here
yeah you know jocko i have uh you know
business owners talk to me about that
all the time you know like why can't i
be a toxic leader you know get get get
the job done you know
get [__] done you know that type of
thing
and it's kind of like you know what you
could be a toxic leader and like you
said you could yell and scream and
people are going to listen to you
they're going to do it
but if you're looking for sustained
success over a long period of time
that's where you know toxic leadership
does not work because toxic leadership
could work for short-term gain but if
you want sustained success over time
that that's not the way to do it
certainly is not
um
fast forward a little bit here and again
if you're listening to me read this i'm
i'm just jumping through various
sections it's it's not going to sound
completely cohesive as i read it but you
get the book and it is completely
cohesive next section i want to read
here is uh to be successful in life you
must make yourself vulnerable there's no
risk without reward with that said the
risk you take must be prudent and must
include risk analysis and risk
mitigation measures nothing is risk-free
and seldom can a person eliminate risk
entirely although risk cannot be
eliminated leaders must
identify ways to reduce the most
probable and highest impact risks
i i think this is funny because
i say to leaders all the time if there's
no risk it's not even a decision what's
the decision if there's no risk and it's
just a benefit cool we're doing it right
we're not even talking that's not a
decision that's just what we're doing
yeah
absolutely and uh
and i think that's why some leaders
fail to have the courage to make
decisions because with almost any
decision you're making there's some sort
of risk associated with that
and uh
again
if if you're going to look at
gaining anything for your organization
you know we talked about you know moving
yourself out of your comfort zone you've
got to move your organization out of its
comfort zone too
and so it's it's it's it's about okay
understanding what those risks are and
then how am i going to reduce the
probability of this happening
and also reduce the impact of it
happening and those those are certain
steps you you could take
you know um i talk about optimism a lot
and especially you know if if you hit a
a really bad day a really bad day
uh
you know you have to be optimistic and
then lead your organization through that
but
it's not just because you're telling
people hey things are going to get
better you've actually got to put a plan
together that's believable to your
followers so it's it's just not about
you know what you say
it's about okay what plan have we put
together now that's that's going to show
that we're going to be able to do things
a little bit differently to overcome
this adversity so
um you know that that that's really and
and it takes a lot of hard work and it
doesn't come easy yeah i always whenever
i talk about you got to believe in the
mission right
and i say believe isn't doesn't mean
the
the old saying if you can believe that
you can achieve it actually not true i i
because i could say i believe i can
fight i'm not gonna be able to fly to me
believe belief in the mission means you
see an actual pathway to achieve the
mission and it might be challenging and
there's going to be bumps and hurdles
and obstacles along the way but we are
going to be able to do it and hey
everyone here's how we're going to get
there and as long as you can show people
an actual pathway to get to this victory
then you can then people can believe in
what you're doing for sure yeah yeah and
uh
you know i'll just reflect back on a bad
day uh you know i had uh january 5th
i think you're familiar with the glass
factory bombing there in ramadi
and uh
you know
you have a bad day like that and you
just
you know
as a leader you you just can't
cave in i mean because so give everyone
a little briefing i mean obviously i i
knew about it i arrived there shortly
thereafter and i tracked it as it
happened i mean it was a horrific
incident
at a police recruiting event so
recruiting local police in the city of
ramadi
to to come and join the the iraqi police
and become the defenders of of the city
and help the local populist what we
talked about earlier defend the populist
here you go come and sign up and it was
actually going pretty well and then this
event happened yeah it was it was going
remarkably well you know when we first
got there i guess it was julian uh or
july of of 2005
uh next june and july up there of course
but july of 2005
uh
you know we we started
uh police recruiting events and we'd
have like
two or three
people show up to join the police i mean
it was pathetic
and you know we started to talk to the
shakes and actually
through
our talks with the shakes they would
tell us some things that our troops were
doing that probably
weren't that beneficial to the
citizens of ramadi uh so we started to
change up some of our tactics and
procedures
that didn't affect our operation but
it helped the shakes understand that hey
we were really here for your people for
your tribe
and this uh really uh demonstrated
itself in in uh january of 2006 we held
this
recruiting event it was january 3rd 4th
and 5th
and on january 3rd we had 200 people
show up at the glass factory in ramadi
where we're conducting this event and
the glass factory is an old factory but
it's a nice big building and it was
right outside or very close to
the main u.s camp of camp ramadi so it's
a pretty good spot today exactly it was
it was a good spot to do it 200 people
showed up the first day it's like we
can't believe this like before we're
having two or three people show up we've
got 200 people standing in line to join
the police
so the shay you know that told us the
shakes were getting the word out to
their tribes people hey come and we we
trust these americans
come in and so the second day
we had around 450 500 people standing in
line to join the police it's like this
is incredible
the
third day and as i reflect back on it
uh you know whenever you're operating in
an insurgency environment you don't want
to do things three days in a row so it
was a big mistake i made
uh third day we had about 800 people
standing in line i mean we were ecstatic
we thought we really turned a corner
here
and
a suicide bomber because this was the
third day in a row we were doing this
suicide bomber shows up
and detonates their vest right in the
middle of this large crowd killing over
100 iraqis
and killed a marine dog handler sergeant
khan and and also a good friend of mine
lieutenant colonel mike mclaughlin
and injured uh several other of our our
soldiers some some severely but thank
god no no one else died no no other us
military died from that attack
and
so that was a really really bad day
the way i handled it is uh i brought the
leaders together the following day
because because two weeks from that
particular day we were going to have 200
iraqis show up at the glass factory
again so we could ship them to baghdad
to attend police training so we knew we
were going to have a similar situation
so got everybody together the next day
and
the importance of leaders admitting when
they do something wrong i think really
comes out here because uh when i got
everybody together i don't know what
they were thinking maybe they were
thinking i was going to try to blame
somebody i don't know but the first
thing i i said was
we're not going to waste time fixing
blame on anybody because because i'm the
one responsible for this so forget about
fixing blame it's it's it's on me
what we need to spend our time doing is
talk about how are we going to change
things so this doesn't happen two weeks
from now when we do the same event again
because you know we had to publicize
this so people knew knew to show show up
so it's not like you're keeping it from
the insurgents and so i'm not going to
get into the details of how we change
things but we change things
significantly
in terms of the way the outside of that
glass factory was set up so
if god forbid a suicide bomber was going
to blow themselves up again the most
they could take out would be about 10
people rather than 100 or more
and so uh the the point is
uh when leaders
hit these bad days this is this
adversity
there's
the organization is counting on you to
find a way through it and and
that that was a lesson i learned i
mentioned you know
uh this book is filled with mistakes i
made that i was able to learn from and
by putting this book out hopefully
others won't have to
make similar mistakes and
so
the whole point of what i just said is
when you hit adversity
you've got to
be able to be resilient enough to fight
your way through that for the
organization and again that's not going
to come
uh by itself you've got to you've got to
prepare and and and develop your
resiliency before these bad days happen
because we all know they're going to
happen
and and then it's also the important
part of a leader admitting they made a
mistake
so the organization doesn't have to
start pointing fingers at one another
because
if if you don't do that and you can't
develop that sense of of of trust where
because people know when you're screwed
up okay
and if people are
are spending more energy
on watching their own back
they're not going to be expending energy
on getting done with the organization
needs to to get done
uh because watching your own back takes
a hell of a lot of energy doesn't it
and so and so that
that's really the moral of the story
yeah no it's a and
you were there when this when we had a
we had a blue on blue that i wrote about
extreme ownership and it's the same you
know the same exact approach i took
which was
hey
there's a friendly iraqi soldier dead
there's several iraqis wounded one of my
guys is wounded who are going to blame
don't look any further than me because
this is on me and it is on me this is
this is happening i'm the senior guy on
the battlefield it's 100 my fault and
that way yeah we don't have to look at
who we're going to point fingers at no
one has to worry about hey am i going to
leave you out the dry i'm not going to
hang you out to dry this is 100 on me
and then we how do we prevent this from
ever happening again it's the the thing
a leader has to do in those situations
yeah
absolutely um
fast forward a little bit here
you talk about creating a vision you say
the concept of a leader providing a
vision to an organization they lead is
at least 2 000 years old
in the kings james version of the bible
proverbs 29 18 reads
where there is no vision the people
perish
an early point in my experience leading
people i became aware that providing a
vision of the future was one of the most
important things a leader can do the
whole concept of leadership is about
taking people to a place where they
could not reach on their own
i have found that when i provide a
vision of the future to a group i lead
it motivates and inspires them to work
toward achieving a desired end state
that is why i believe creating a shared
vision and communicating it consistently
are important roles of a leader
visualizing achievement is essential if
you are to gain success
a vision must be a simple unique ideal
image of the future ideally the vision a
leader develops should be a shared
vision
a shared vision not only
does not only mean everyone in the
organization believes in the vision but
also that represents a representative
members of the organization have
provided input to create the vision
occasionally i'll get i talk about
decentralized command all the time with
all the companies i work with and
occasionally i'll get someone saying hey
you know i
i i feel like that the team doesn't
really know where we're going and i'm
trying to lead them in the right
direction but i don't want to impose it
on them and and
i say listen
it is okay
for a leader sometimes to say hey
everyone this is where we're going
because not everyone has the visibility
that you have from your leadership
perspective you know if you're in charge
of a project not everyone can see all
the moving pieces so they might not see
hey this is where we need to go this is
what we're doing
is it good to get input for that
collective vision absolutely absolutely
but you may be in a situation where
other members of the team don't have the
vision that you have because just
because of where you're sitting
or where you're standing you can see a
little bit more you have a little bit
more visibility on things so sometimes
you do have to make the vision and as
soon as you make that vision your vision
doesn't isn't uh written in stone or you
shouldn't write your vision in stone if
you write your vision in stone you're
probably making a mistake and some
people might think that that sounds weak
well you know what are you going to
change your vision actually i may change
the vision if we get to a point where we
need to do something just like when
you're in ramada you say hey wait a
second we've been doing things like this
we are not getting any progress with the
shakes the shakes are telling us oh
guess what we're going to do adjust our
vision so there's nothing wrong with
adjusting your vision and there's
nothing wrong with if you're not getting
feedback it's okay cool watch this
here's the vision here's what we're
gonna do start moving that direction
adapt as needed yeah yeah you know uh
totally agree
uh
one one thing i learned when got this is
back uh
around late 90s
around the year 2000 was before 9 11.
uh when i took command of 55th brigade
uh you know national guard brigade so
you know about 3 000 soldiers
distributed across northeastern
pennsylvania down toward the
philadelphia area and
you know 85 of them
had full-time civilian jobs so
like man i gotta develop a vision for
this organization in order for us to
show some you know to move forward here
and what i did is i went around uh to
representative uh samplings of soldiers
who were part of that brigade i would
talk to a pfc
that had like a year in the army you
know i would talk to a major who had you
know maybe 16 17 years in the army and
and every in a few folks in between
there i mean 3 000 soldiers you can't
talk to all of them and say hey where do
you want to see this brigade go
and and uh the question i would ask them
i would say hey you know if you fell
asleep for five years and woke up five
years from now what would you want to
see this brigade look like then you know
and uh the funny thing is whether it was
a soldier
low rank one year experience or higher
ranking officer with 17 years experience
everybody kind of wanted the same thing
they wanted to be well trained so if we
had to deploy we'd be able to do our job
successfully and that ended up
essentially what what what the vision
was so what it taught me
uh and this goes for any business leader
out there trying to develop a vision for
their organization and many
organizations are working distributed
now uh you know with the pandemic and
everything else
it's try to get it you know when i say
shared vision try to get a
representative sample if you could of
where people would like to see it go and
ultimately you as the leader like you
said
you you've got a broader view of
everything so yeah it's
you've finally got to put a stake in the
ground say yeah this is going to be our
vision but i think it's a good idea to
get a representative
sampling of those in your organization
and and then
you know when you get it out there
you know you you've gotta you've gotta
share it in a in a multitude of ways you
know when you're speaking to people one
on one you've gotta communicate that
vision when you're speaking to a group
of 500 you've got to communicate the
vision through email through your
website through
whatever you know social media means you
you might uh want to use but the vision
then has to be consistent you know it
can't be a a new flavor of the month or
a new vision of the quarter you know
like you said visions could change but
it shouldn't it shouldn't be changing on
a very very frequent basis so that
that's what i learned about developing a
vision you know over 20 years ago yeah
and it's it's it's always interesting
like that's alignment right no matter
who you talk to
you talk to a front-line individual
that's been in the army for six months
you talk to someone that's been in the
army for 20 years
enlisted officer on both ends of that
spectrum and they all say oh well i'd
like that if we get deployed we're ready
to do our job
you can make so many decisions based on
that just knowing that right there hey
is it going to help us do our job if we
spend time you know clowning around at
work on our drill weekend is it going to
help us be ready to do our job no it's
not so let's do something else
and that goes up and down the chain of
command and now that we have that shared
aligned vision now we can all make a
bunch of decisions just based on the
fact that we know that when we deploy we
want to be ready to do our job we want
to be effective okay
does this help us be effective or not
and we can make a decision
so that's important stuff
um
fast forward a little bit you know this
got a chapter in here called keeping
your feet on the ground which is about
humility uh you say i worked for an
arrogant leader before it was not any
fun all of us who worked for this man
felt our opinions were not valued he was
the kind of guy who said things like
when i want your opinion i'll tell you
what it is
stereotypical military but not actual
military we believed we were not
respected and we felt more like objects
rather than we were part of the team the
result was our initiative imagination
and creativity were stifled as you could
imagine the leader failed
again this is a this is one of those
false
images of military leadership does it
happen yes it does happen
and and here's something else i'll tell
you about this
you want to know why it does happen more
often in the military
and one of the reason it happens more
often in the military is because in the
military you're only in command for two
years generally speaking
so
mostly enlisted guys you're working for
a jerk or an arrogant person it takes
them three months or
three to six months to go hey this guy
really is arrogant then at six months
they're like oh god what are we gonna do
about it this guy's horrible now it's a
year now they start thinking hey we
should really do something about this we
should get rid of this guy we should run
up the chain of command we should fill
out our surveys our command climate
surveys and report what a jerk this guy
is and then it's 18 months and then they
go you know he's gonna be gone in six
months let's just freaking deal with it
and that guy never gets the feedback and
so everything that he did worked and
it's positive feedback and it's a
positive feedback loop he thinks he did
a good job because he yelled and
screamed and didn't take anyone's
opinion and now he gets promoted that's
the unfortunate reality of the military
yeah and the other interesting thing
with that you know we could call that
guy a toxic leader is i've found that
toxic leaders
are very good at not letting their
people they work for their superior
officers whatever you want to call it
see their toxicity oh for sure they're
able to hide it i've known a lot of
military leaders that
everyone above them in the chain of
command loved them everybody below the
chain of command hated them yeah yeah
because above the chain of command they
see someone that's making stuff happen
right below the chain of command they're
getting they're the ones that are
freaking being driven to you know bloody
fingers as they try and get the job done
and yeah that happens
often yeah it's amazing how good they
are at hiding that toxicity when they're
talking to somebody who who they work
for yeah and you've got to be careful as
a leader to make sure that that's not
happening that's why it's important like
you said to go down and
talk to the troops yeah and say hey
what's what's echo charles like as a
leader how's that going and you know
what they're going to say at first and
say he's he's great
but you got to ask him well how often
does he talk to you does he take her you
know you got to dig it out of them
because most of them they don't want to
they don't want to they don't want to
make they don't want that beef as echo
would say yeah
[Music]
and you know the the more you get down
there you know i call it money muddy
boots leadership the more you get down
there to talk to the troops you know
whether it be military civilian
uh
then you're able to develop that trust
too because you're right the first time
you go down and ask somebody hey how's
it going they're not going to be totally
honest with you if they don't know you
but the more they get used to seeing you
come around and just having a rapport
and see that you're hey normal guy and
you really do want the best food
organization yeah they're going to
loosen up and tell you the truth also
don't burn your sources you know yeah
don't go back and say
hey echo i need to talk to you
john gronski said you were a tyrant and
all that
you're never going to get any
information again no so you got to be
careful about that one uh fast forward a
little bit one of the best ways a leader
could show respect to others is by
asking for their opinion and then
seriously considering it leaders
empowers others in an organization
simply by listening
to stay level-headed and keep one's feet
placed firmly on the ground leaders must
acknowledge others for their
contributions to this team's success so
this is something i've i've written
about
talking about
listening is i think is the most
underrated
possibly the most underrated
aspect of leadership the only other one
that's in a close second and it
correlates very directly is asking
earnest questions ask ernest questions
and then
listen to what people have to say
and and you know uh some leaders think
they're listening
uh but their actions don't show that
they're listening you know like you're
going to talk to somebody hey hey could
i have a minute could i talk to you
and you know the leader is you know
checking their phone while you're
talking to them or they're you know
tapping something on the keyboard or
their computer while you're talking to
them or you're talking to them they're
looking off at somebody else you know
it's kind of like wow is this guy really
listening to me yeah you know that
leader might think they're listening but
their actions are showing that they're
not really listening so it's it's
important that you you really do that
active listening actually listen yeah
yeah
fast forward a little bit identify your
core values to develop strong character
you must take the time to figure out
what you stand for and what your core
values really are this came to light for
me many years ago i attended a dinner at
which the speaker gave an impassioned
talk about his own personal core values
the next day as i was still thinking
about what i heard i realized if someone
asked me what my personal core values
were i would not be able to give an
answer sure i had values i tried to be
an ethical person but to that point i
never took the time to think long and
hard about exactly what i stood for and
my principles i never took the time to
consider what values were most important
to me
important
you know uh the other thing about values
if if you don't understand what your own
personal core values are
when you make personal decisions or when
it comes to time for you to make a
personal decision about something
i really believe
you have to factor your your personal
core values in the decisions you make so
if you don't have those
core values
articulated in your own mind how are you
going to factor them in to your decision
and the same with organizations
you know organization many organizations
have organizational values
but when the leadership team gets
together with the ceo
and they're in the you know they're
going through this decision making
process
how many of them actually factor the
organizational values into the decision
that they're making
uh which i i would think
i would just guess many don't even think
about their values when they're making a
business decision yeah which is crazy to
think about if you're making decisions
that you might as well just be making
decisions in the blind
exactly and then and then you're not
being true to your values and again that
breaks trust with your customers or that
breaks trust through your employees or
whomever
that particular decision is going to
affect so yeah really
that that's why values are so important
i believe and and then the other thing
um
behaviors i think are important too you
know i know a lot of organizations are
getting
uh you know they do have organizational
values but now they're also getting into
organizational behaviors so they
actually
list out you know maybe between 10 to 20
behaviors that they expect from their
employees which i think is
is uh very important as a matter of fact
a consulting firm i used to work for
greencastle consulting
uh has
expected behaviors that they want their
consultants to demonstrate
and i i think that's a very good way to
look at things because you know values
are kind of conceptual
behaviors are more tangible
and and i do think uh talk you know uh
identifying expected behaviors is really
helpful in in getting your employees to
treat customers or treat each other the
way you want them to
yeah this is uh something that i was
acutely aware of
especially with kids and when i wrote
the first warrior kid book
the whole pr actually the entire premise
of the first book is
the kid has to come up with a warrior
kid code of what he's gonna and and his
uncle in the this book it's a kid's book
but the kid's uncle is uh was it was in
the seal teams and so he introduces him
he can see that the kid's kind of
floating around not making the best
decisions and so he says hey
warriors live by a code and i point out
you know the marine corps values the
the the ranger code the i just point out
the um uh the ancient you know the
samurai code the viking and i put them
all in the book
and say hey you need to make your own
code and the kid ends up writing his own
code and the uncle approves it this
warrior kid code and then eventually i
wrote another book called the code the
evaluation of protocols which literally
has like a code saying hey as an adult
you still need a code you still need to
figure out what it is you're trying to
do what are you trying to do with your
life and if again if you have this code
in place hey i want to be healthy cool
is that donut going to help me be
healthy no it's not don't eat it hey i
want to be uh i want to spend quality
time with my family okay why am i
watching tv right now
okay don't watch tv if you have
something to live by then it's gonna
make your life that much better and and
that's why the the warrior kid code and
the code the evaluation the protocol
that's the purpose of those say hey
listen
and in both those cases i say write your
own code because you shouldn't follow my
code
but i can pretty much guarantee you most
people would have an 80 overlap on what
their code is going to be i mean i might
be more into you know martial arts than
someone else might be more into fishing
but
if you're going to focus on some part of
your life there's going to be an 80 who
doesn't want to be healthy who doesn't
want to have a good family who doesn't
want to be financially successful who
wants to save money like all these
things
it's a 90 solution and maybe you can
make some small adjustments to it but to
wander through life without that stuff
is exactly that it's wandering through
life yeah you know jocko i think you
putting that uh emphasis on code in in
that book
is one of the best things you've ever
done
because if you want to keep people on an
ethical path one of the
guard rails to to stay on that ethical
path is by actually writing down what
your own personal code is
and then that will help you stay
grounded and help you stay on that path
that that's just a great technique to
use to keep somebody you know staying
within those limits because how many
times have we seen ceos ceos governors
you know stray ethically
off the path presidents yeah presidents
you know anyone in the chain of command
bottom to the top yeah and and again
it's because they either never took the
time to write down their own personal
code or if they've written it down now
they're not paying attention to it so i
think that's great advice you gave out
there
um
this is one of the sections where i
actually
made a note of what your action section
of the book so here here's the actions
and you did this for every one of these
sections
you get you identify actions to actually
take to move forward and improve this
area of leadership so here the actions
are identify your own personal core
values
ensure your personal personal core
values and the values of the
organization you work for are aligned
when making a decision
factor your personal values and your
organization's values into your decision
making process
strive to place the welfare and interest
of your followers ahead of your own
and and those are some things some
actions that you can take to
make this a reality and hey identify
your own personal core values and write
them down it's something everybody
should do
um
section here
called uh cultivating trust
and you you get in this situation where
it's 1999
um
you're going to lithuania
uh let me go to the book here the
country had regained its independence
only about six years earlier it was
going to be my job to work with the
lithuanian military to help them
understand how the us military
functioned and grow the relationship
between the u.s and lithuania i would
have a team of three other u.s military
personnel representing the marines army
and air force and the team would also
include one lithuanian army officer and
three lithuanian civilians and this is
you're coming off i think you're coming
off a battalion command at this point so
you were just done leading 800 people
and now you got a team of
seven
you arrive in lithuania for this job
and i gotta read this part
after i was on board for a couple weeks
i began to come up with what i thought
were some excellent ideas instead of
tackling the work myself i gave began to
shoot off yellow sticky notes to
everyone giving them tasks to do i had
plenty of bright ideas and i shot off
plenty of taskers to them i thought i
was making a great impression on the
team because of my exceptional ideas
however i could not explain it but
something seemed to be a miss somehow i
did not feel the team was comfortable
under my leadership i had an army
reserve major working on my team as an
operations officer he was a bright guy
with an analytical mind and positive
demeanor one morning when i was sitting
in my office he knocked on my door and
asked if he could speak to me privately
i brightened up i was all about this i
thought to myself there is a young
officer who needs advice from a sage
like me
the major sat down and i asked him what
was on his mind
his answer floored me he said sir you
are tearing this team apart
he went on to say that since i arrived
morale was at an all-time low the team's
perception of my leadership performance
was 180 degrees from what i was hoping
for their perception was not the boss is
a sharp guy he has great ideas rather
their perception was negative including
such thoughts as the new boss thinks
things are all screwed up here the new
boss thinks we are all screwed up the
new boss thinks we have nothing to do
the new boss does not trust us
notice the us versus him attitude that
developed here this was definitely a
lesson learned for me thankfully i had
someone on the team with enough guts to
discuss the issue with me i thank the
major for the personal and moral courage
he displayed by discussing the issue
with me i had no idea that through my
behavior and tone i was giving everyone
such a negative perception of how i
thought they were performing
you go on here fast forward a little bit
what i did to to repair trust i
immediately met with the team members
and apologized for the mistake i made i
took full ownership of creating a
perception that i did not trust them i
told them i trusted them completely i
explained to them that i now realized
how my behavior was negatively affecting
the team i promised them i would change
my behavior
that's a good story yeah
and the freaking battalion commander
post post battalion commander rolling in
the good idea fairy is what we call that
you know and and that taught me that
whether you lead an organization of 800
or you lead an organization of eight
the leadership challenges are there you
know it it doesn't
it doesn't get any easier or harder
depending on the number of people you
lead you know you still got those
challenges
uh the the folks on your team are still
expecting you to be a good leader a
positive influence on them and uh
as i mentioned in the book i'm just glad
uh that this this guy had the the
personal courage to come up and and and
and tell me about it because it was
really it was really life-changing for
me because that really got me on a uh a
journey to
really study what trust is all about and
not only how to cultivate trust but also
how to repair trust if if you
unfortunately break it you know and one
thing that is nice is luckily you must
have given him some kind of a impression
that you were somewhat approachable
and
i can guarantee you there's pro the
the fitness reports of the world and
evaluations are littered with people
that decided they were gonna go tell
their boss hey this is what it looks
like and they get scorched for it
because the person didn't have an open
mind and didn't really want to hear them
so
luckily
you had an open mind and were humble
enough to say oh
that's not good i i made a mistake
unfortunately
the bosses that oftentimes need that
sort of
personal guidance
are the types of bosses that aren't open
to that type of personal guidance
unfortunately yeah yeah scary
i'm glad you i'm glad you complimented
his moral courage yeah no i i realized
how hard that that was for him and and
and again i think that you know the
lesson for anybody out here listening is
hey
you know you you could be
you know you could be a jackass you know
if you want to be and not be
approachable and you know hey my way or
the highway i'm the boss you know who
are you to tell me
what to do or give me advice but
you're probably only gonna go so far in
in you know your journey as a as a
leader and if you really want to have
long-term success you've you've got to
follow some of these basic leadership
tenants
you know
next chapter what leadership is all
about and and and you have a great
combat story about uh
was a gunnery sergeant yeah gunnery
sergeant burkhardt or master sergeant
mike he retired as a master sergeant
outstanding um just
a real real show of courage you told the
story on the last podcast you recite it
with some more detail in here in the
book just of a of a guy that just is
unstoppable um so i
i won't cover that right now get the
book to read that story
um
but you do say this about leadership
effective leadership is measured by the
results an organization achieves after
all organizations exist to achieve their
purpose and attain results leaders
cannot attain results on their own
leaders must enlist the support of their
followers to be successful when leaders
demonstrate to followers they care by
placing their followers welfare ahead of
their own that is a great way for the
leader to gain follower support
former army chief of staff general
gordon sullivan in his book hope is not
a method says our effectiveness as
leaders is not so much what we do is as
in what influence as what we influence
others to do
a leader must inspire others to be their
best and to work toward achieving
organizational objectives a leader is
nothing without support
of those he or she leads using the model
of character competence direction and
overcoming adversity is a framework for
enlisting and retaining support which
will lead to organizational results and
success
if you're doing your job as a leader the
the team is going to be doing what
they're supposed to be doing yeah don't
forget that
and and you know uh it
it it's all about you know
being fortunate enough to have people
around you like like a gunny michael
burkhart and
one other
quick story one tell that's that's not
in the book i didn't mention it last
time uh but i i think it's inspiring we
have this one soldier from the 28th
infantry division who came to ramadi
with us his name was anthony jorgensen
and uh again we got there in uh july of
2005. it was in the fall of 2005. he was
in an up armored humvee i believe it was
in the gunners position
id
detonates
uh causes his up armored humvee to flip
over on its side he ends up having a
broken arm and i think a broken leg both
and so
gets sent back home to the united states
recovers from his wounds
and it was sometime in early 2006
he tells the leadership in the
pennsylvania guard hey i want to go back
over to ramadi you know it's like they
can't believe it's kind of like no we
are not sending you back
so
i did have a battalion from the vermont
national guard there with me task
organized my brigade
so so this guy
leaves the pennsylvania national guard
joins the vermont national guard
just so he could
get vermont to send them back over to
ramadi be part of that battalion so he
gets back over there
and then it's april 2006.
he's out there on another patrol
and he's in a support by fire position
he's in the the gunners compartment of
this up armored humvee there's some
dismounts going into a building
uh that ins they uh believed insurgents
were in
and an insurgent fires an rpg a rocket
propeller grenade
at this up armored humvee that jorgensen
is in
and and just like
wings it you know
slight damage to the humvee
uh he gets knocked down out of the the
gunners hatch gets back up there he sees
that insurgents are pinning down these
dismounts that are out there
so he jumps down into the driver's
compartment
drives that up armored humvee between
where the insurgents are firing and
these uh dismounts that were pinned down
gets back up into the gunner's
compartment and lays down suppressive
fire on these insurgents allowing these
dismounts to to disengage and then can
continue to mission
all this after suffering these wounds
and that attack back in the fall
now how many
you know
how how many people would
you know leave ramadi with with you know
honorable wounds like he did and then
fight to get back over there and then
you know does this heroic action uh
which i believe he got a bronze star
with v4 for
for doing what he did but just just
again the reason i want to bring that
story up is
these soldiers are so inspiring and and
and you know you know we think as
leaders we should be inspiring our
followers but our followers have a way
especially in the military of inspiring
us and some of these stories just have
to be told
anthony jorgensen what's he doing now do
you know yeah he lives up in the
scranton area and he's getting after it
in this grand area yeah he is so just
just very proud of him you know what he
does for a living um offhand i don't
know right on yeah but uh
well we salute you anthony jorgensen
yeah he needs that shout out what a
beast yeah
yeah i mean you get blown up by an ied
and thrown out of your vehicle like you
say oh he he had these wounds you he's
lucky to be alive yeah after that
happens yeah and then you get hit with
an rpg
you're lucky to be alive in a humvee
yeah
and uh again i hope he's playing the
lottery up there anthony jorgensen it's
grant p.a
he's got some luck
he's a guy i'd want you know watching my
back any any time awesome awesome stuff
uh here's an interesting title
do not for a chapter do not treat
everyone equally
talk to us about that yeah basically
what what that's about is uh
you know
i don't think leaders should treat
everybody on the on the team equally uh
you got and when i say that that's what
i mean by you got to get to know the the
people on your team everybody's a little
bit different so you got to really get
to know what makes them tick
and and what's going to motivate certain
people as opposed to motivating others
and so uh you know you can't treat them
equal i think there's a story in there i
think about uh
jimmy johnson when he coached the dallas
cowboys and he was asked by a reporter
hey you know if if you uh saw troy
aikman asleep in one of your team
meetings and a third string offensive
guard asleep in in
in your team meeting would you treat
them the same way
and and he answered absolutely not he
goes and this is what i do he goes i
would probably cut that third string
offensive guard immediately and with
troy aikman i would go up to him and i
would kind of nudge him gently awake and
i would say hey could i bring you a cup
of coffee you know so the point is you
know
you've got to understand the talent you
have on your team and and not everybody
should be treated equal you know some
some people need a kick in the butt some
people need a pat on the back
um
another interesting story with this a
football story you know i i grew up as a
green bay packer fan so in 1966 10 years
old lombardi you know winning his first
super bowl i became a packer fan so i
started to read all kinds of books about
the packers and there's this one story
you know bart starr who was the
quarterback for for lombardi
uh
i think it was like the second year
lombardi was the head coach he was just
chewing bart start out relentlessly
during this practice
and you know talk about moral courage uh
after practice uh bart starr goes to
coach lombardi's office and he goes hey
coach could i talk to you privately for
a few minutes
coach says yeah sure what's up and star
says to him he goes coach he goes i
don't want you ever chewing me out in
front of the team again he said i'm the
quarterback i'm leading this team he
goes if if they see you chewing me out
the way you were chewing me out he goes
i'm not going to be able to lead this
team effectively and lombardi light bulb
went off in his head and he realized he
could not treat everybody exactly the
same way you know so he never chewed
bart star out in front of the team again
because he realized that hey what star
said was exactly correct you know he
couldn't lead the team effectively if he
was going to be treated like that
and uh so again just just some
great lessons we could learn from from
from from past leaders and you know i've
just tried i think we all try to do our
best when we hear these lessons to try
to apply them if we could you know
that's when you get a guy like vince
lombardi and the reputation that he has
and he's humble enough to think oh
if he if he can be humble in that
situation and maybe listen to one of his
subordinates and say oh he's right i'm
wrong that's another indicator that you
might want to stay humble as a leader
you got some stuff to learn no matter
who you are yeah absolutely
uh you talked earlier about muddy boots
leadership and and you tell a story in
here about
you got complimented on the fact that
you were in charge but you you were your
boots were muddy because you've been out
in the field going
seeing what was happening and
and that's a whole concept of get in the
field get out there talk to people find
what's going on in the front lines um
you say this here a mentor in that same
chapter you say a mentor of mine told me
the personal presence of a leader is
probably the greatest key to influencing
the action once a plan has been put into
motion a leader's presence demonstrates
to one's followers the importance of the
work at hand when the leader is where
the action is
they are then positioned to motivate
others and make timely adjustments when
necessary
leader sometimes has to go and make
things happen yeah you know i remember
as a young army officer reading in some
manual somewhere
uh or maybe it was even some senior
leader who was coaching me
but said you know through there's three
things a commander could do
to positively impact the battle once it
begins
he said the commander's use of fires you
know close air support and indirect fire
um
the
use of the reserves you know because
usually the commander
retains the authority of when to use his
reserve and the third thing is personal
presence on the battlefield and he said
those are the three things a commander
could do
to influence the battle once it begins
uh and and that always stuck to me stuck
with me especially that notion of the
personal presence on on the battlefield
and just having that personal presence
there
uh which help uh i think you know
soldiers in in battle or in the civilian
sector uh you know employees in an
organization
realize that hey this leader is out with
us sharing the load
sharing the danger
uh you know sharing what's coming our
way
and and and you know they they kind of
get bolstered by by that whole notion
well i i can attest to that i remember
seeing you out on the battlefield in
ramadi looking over and say well there's
the brigade commander
roger that i guess he's i guess he's not
uh sitting back in the talk all the time
he's out here with the troops like you
said uh
seeing what's happening
understanding what's happening and
taking that risk i mean if you were in
ramadi and you were out in the city you
were at risk and ieds and and roadside
bombs and rpgs and and machine guns
don't they don't care what your name is
they don't care what your rank is
they'll they'll they'll kill you one way
or the other if they want to yeah and
you know i did try to get out there a
lot not because i had any type of uh
you know courage to speak of but just
because i felt it was necessary to do
and the other thing for any military
leader listening to this and really
it applies to business leaders too
i would encourage my staff to get out
there
and and the reason i encourage my staff
to get out there is because i felt it
was important for my staff to also gain
ground truth if if the staff was gaining
what they thought was the truth from
reading reports
they were missing about 80 percent of
what was happening so
although i know you know in the military
a lot of times especially in operations
like that the staff needs to be back
doing staff work
i always encourage them that hey they
did have to make time to actually get
out there
talk to troops
see areas with their own eyes
and again just a history from less than
hurtkin forest 28th infantry division
fighting in the hurricane forest in
in november uh 1944 the battle of
schmidt
was a devastating
time for the 28th infantry division in
about four days over six thousand
casualties
and one thing that was written about
that period is uh
it said that general kota who was a
division commander at the time
most reports i read said he never even
went as far forward as one of his
regimental command posts and the staff
did not
go forward either so
they didn't realize that the call trail
through the hurricane forest which they
were sending
sherman tanks down a sherman tank
is eight and a half feet wide the call
trail was nine feet wide i mean it was
not a good um you know mains you know
msr main supply route uh or or good
route of any sort for those tanks to be
going along and so the lesson there is
because the commander didn't get out on
the battlefield because the staff didn't
get out there they're relying on maps
they didn't get the full uh
understanding of what that hurricane
forest area was was like so
again for any civilian leader any
military leader absolutely important not
only to get out there yourself but to
get your your staff the ones that you
depend on to advise you to get out there
as well
yeah there's another piece of this one
when you are the leader and you what
you're supposed to be doing is you're
supposed to be detached you're not
supposed to go out there and get in the
firefight you're not supposed to go out
there and and run the marketing meeting
or meet with the client necessarily
or get and start manufacturing stuff on
the line you're supposed to go out and
look do you do you maybe do a couple
moves on the manufacturing line to make
sure you understand what's happening yes
but you don't start manufacturing things
you come in from a different perspective
you come in with a different perspective
and then what you have to look for as a
leader
is you have to make sure that things are
going in the right direction and the
test that you should put on yourself is
like it the basically the momentum is
the momentum that we're going in correct
because the momentum could be wrong
and the momentum could be right and if
the momentum is right cool you can just
get out of the way if the momentum is
wrong that's where you're gonna have to
step in and stop it and and one of the
places where you see this is
well in combat when things lag
you know you get an element that's not
moving as quickly as they're supposed to
move they're lagging they're moving too
slow and they don't even realize that
they they can't realize it because
they're doing it you can come in and say
hey we got to step it up hey we need to
push that next building so when when an
element is lagging a leader can step in
and move things quicker
and they should because that's the the
momentum is inertia the momentum is hey
we're we're going slow we're being
methodical but they need to move faster
the leader's got to make that happen
there's also times where the leader
steps in and says hey
i need to slow down guys are moving too
quick you guys are taking you not not uh
taking too many risks slow it down
so there's all these situations where i
think what the leader needs to be
cognitive cognitive of in their mind
when they step into these situations is
is the momentum we have is the crowd as
the mob moving in the right direction if
they are great get out of their way let
them keep going but if they're not
that's when your opportunity comes to uh
straighten it out and check it yeah yeah
it's not and it's not just about speed
it's about tempo and a couple of things
came to mind jaco as you were talking
one is
[Music]
my personal security detachment in
ramadi uh you know it was generally for
up armored humvees i had a platoon the
platoon leader's name was jacques smith
just just an excellent
leader
and uh
early on as we were out there with me
you know uh being transported by this
uh when we when we moved mounted by this
uh four up armor humvee formation
um
you know i was kind of on the radio
directing the movement of these four up
armored humvees and and uh jack smith
you know the lieutenant he looks at me
goes sir he goes
you're you're leading the brigade he
goes let me lead this platoon
and i and i said you know what jack
you're exactly right i'm going to shut
up you know we're out when i when we're
out here this is your platoon you're
going to lead it i'm going i'm not going
to say a damn word uh
about how how you should maneuver this
platoon because he was right i had i had
a a brigade elite and then the other
story is command sergeant major uh chris
kepner he was my command sergeant major
when i commanded 28th infantry division
he used to say
as he would go out and talk to leaders
and coach and mentor leaders he would he
would say
leaders could stop things from getting
screwed up just by the fact that they
were there just by their mere presence
uh so you know
that's why it's so important again you
know for for leaders to get out there
because
people are going to do the right thing
and adhere to those standards when they
know the leader is is there
i was uh
down in florida a while back doing some
leadership training for a sheriff's
department down there and one of the
the deputy sheriff's was speaking to a
group of corporals and he told the story
how in the in the in the jail there
uh how
um
some deputies that should have been in
the kitchen watching the prisoners do
what they were doing
uh you know cooking the meal
just neglected to be there as they
should
and things really got out of hand
and his point was
just because
the sergeant wasn't going down and
checking to make sure those deputies
were doing the right thing they you know
they're human beings they just decided
hey you know this mustn't be that
important because nobody's checking on
us so we're not going to be doing the
right thing and so his point was again
just by the mere fact of a leader being
present they're going to fix things just
by being there
this is a reminds me of of another
chapter in the book here chapter 11 an
organization's personality you say in
1985 i took command of an infantry
company in the 28th infantry division
pennsylvania national guard the infantry
company i commanded was designated alpha
company 2nd battalion 109th infantry and
the unit had an authorized strength 144
soldiers i was honored to have an
opportunity to lead the commissioned
officers non-commissioned officers and
soldiers assigned to the outfit i
remembered reading an army leadership
manual earlier in the in my career
before taking this command
in the manual there was a statement i
will never forget it's at a military
unit
and any organization for that matter
takes on the personality of its leader
when reading that statement as a young
inexperienced leader i doubted it i
could not believe a unit of almost 150
soldiers would take on my personality i
do not believe someone like me could
have that type of impact whereby over a
hundred
of the people assigned would take on my
traits based on my experience commanding
that company i learned i was wrong and
the leadership manual is correct an
organization will take on the
personality of its leader in my case the
commander i took over for was a good man
however his focus seemed to be more on
being a nice guy than on emphasizing
physical fitness and tough training that
was exactly what the person personality
of the unit was when i took command
everyone got along everyone was
comfortable but many of the soldiers
were relaxed on their fitness levels and
the unit did not go into the field much
to conduct rigorous training i believe
soldiers need to be in excellent
physical condition and i also believed
infantry soldiers needed to train
rigorously in field conditions be
experts with their weapons and take
excellent care of their equipment over
time the unit took on a tough persona
this was ratified by our brigade
commander when he selected our unit to
train at the national training center at
fort irwin california in late 1980s this
was a big deal and an honor for a
national guard company to be selected
for that training so there you go
yeah
case in point yeah
the the next section i wanted to just
jump into and it's called decision
making and there's some tap some topics
in here that you write about
and i i just want to kind of do a high
level review of some of these
some of these uh
sections one of them is hit the ground
running
which means when you show up get started
um get your butt in gear yeah yeah
another one's character is foundational
again this is what we're doing
what we're doing this is who we are and
if we don't have good character hey
listen
if you don't have good character you
might be able to get away with it for a
little while you might even be able to
weasel out a promotion because you you
maneuvered and you manipulated and and
you took credit where you didn't and you
didn't give credit to the team or you
still you you might you might even get a
promotion you might even get two
promotions it can happen
but eventually it's not it's not going
to last no no you know uh
a friend of mine len morella he
graduated from west point in like 1958
or something
retired as a colonel in the army he
wrote this book
about character and in the book he would
go and interview different leaders who
were known to be character-based leaders
and one of the
people he interviewed was coach
krashewski coach k from duke
and uh
in the in this interview he was doing
with coach k he you know len len said to
coach k hey like what does character
have to do with winning a basketball
game
and coach k's answer was you know
character
has absolutely nothing
at all to do with winning a basketball
game
but
it has everything to do
with winning a championship
you know and exactly what you say you
know you might have a win here or there
if you're not character based but if you
want to be a champion if you want to
have long-term success you you got to be
a character based leader at least that's
what i believe
um another sub headline here is know
your job and do your job
and this
my note that i took on this one is
there is such a thing as a stupid
question and let me explain that you
know people say oh there's no such thing
as a stupid question if you show up
to a job
and you're going to be in charge of a
tank and you say hey what's the name of
this vehicle how far can this gun shoot
how many rounds can we get if you're
asking questions that you should have
done some research and know when you
showed up you're wrong if you show up to
a manufacturer to run a manufacturing
plant and you show up and say hey what
is it we're making or how many employees
do we have or who's in charge of the day
shift if you're asking questions that a
little bit of research could have
answered
you didn't do a good job preparing you
don't you so
know your job that's my part of know
your job there is stupid questions don't
show up your first day and ask stupid
questions that you should have known if
you had taken an ounce of effort to to
figure out what was happening
no
you know you're exactly right i mean uh
you got to put forth some of that effort
now if it's some type of
you know inane you know technical
you know thing that maybe a guy with 10
years experience would know and you
wouldn't know hey that's that's fine and
you can ask those questions all day long
yeah yeah but it's just showing you
really don't care
if if you didn't you know take the time
to do that type of research before
coming into the job for sure
uh you say take on tough assignments
and this is
there's a this is this is just a good
thing across the board you're gonna
learn a lot
you're gonna show everyone that you
don't you'll take the not just the tough
ones but the crappy ones
hey no one wants to work this weekend
cool i got it
um
one of my buddies
uh seth stone who's in ramadi with us he
was he was on a ship he was a ship
driver in the navy and they had his his
department got assigned to do some
cleaning like they hadn't been in port
for a while and his
department got assigned to clean
whatever
and uh i heard this after he died
someone
the story got passed to his brother was
uh you know as as his department was
leaving for liberty
they looked up and they saw he was
cleaning whatever it was they were
assigned to clean and he had just said
you know what i'm gonna let the guys go
and go on liberty and i'm gonna do
whatever menial task we've been told to
do and he was the guy in charge of the
department so do the do the tough ones
do the crappy ones too yeah yeah and
again you know all in line with hit the
ground running you know a lot of people
say don't volunteer for anything right
you know i i think that's a big mistake
i mean you you got a volunteer to take
on those tough things and and
when you do that uh you know a couple of
benefits first of all nobody's gonna
expect you to succeed if you're just
starting you're you know out in your
career uh you know you're not going to
have high expectations if you're just
starting out and so by tackling those
tough things gaining that experience
uh you know it's just like you know in
the military you know a second
lieutenant in the army the lowest
ranking commissioned officer you're
expecting a second lieutenant to make a
mistake you know so that that's the time
to take on those tough assignments gain
that experience make some of those
mistakes
learn from them
and uh you know hopefully have the right
leaders guiding you along the way and
that that's how you're really going to
get off to a good start and be
successful
another one um develop your leadership
philosophy early but continue to refine
and this is
once again important even vince lombardi
refined his philosophy
and that's what you need to do come up
with a philosophy but then refine it
make it better as time goes on
um
next section here is is
uh competence and i don't know if you
did this on purpose but some of your
chapter titles have a little bit of uh
you know
you're gonna get some arise out of some
people this one's not everyone deserves
a mentor
yeah i kind of did that on purpose all
right what do you mean by that one
uh you know and again this gets back to
uh
uh an infantry conference i was at uh
and and general cohn you know he since
passed away but he was i think the
tradoc commander at the time
speaking to us there and he basically
said that during his remarks and it's
like wow you know that kind of hit me
you know like like a brick hitting me in
the face it's like well what's he
talking about
uh but but what he went on to say and
and which what i have you know come to
to see as true is
you know not everybody deserves a mentor
because if you're not out there actively
looking for a mentor for somebody to
you know somebody's example to follow
you probably don't deserve a mentor and
i remember even as a as a young officer
thinking
you know hey nobody's mentoring me you
know what's up with this you know and i
was expecting some you know uh graybeard
you know to sit me down at their side
and and tell me all the facts of how to
lead but hey that that doesn't happen
and then i realized mentorship is
happening all around us all we got to do
is look for it for so again if if you're
a young executive in a company
uh
you know uh and and and you're observing
how
one of the senior leaders in that
company
is
acting how they're talking to people how
they're relating to people
and you're learning the good and the bad
from that that's actually mentorship
uh and and you know mentorship is all
around us if we took just look for it
but nobody should expect somebody to
kind of sit us down and and tell us
about hey these these are the things you
really got to look out for that that's
not realistic that's that's just just
not going to happen
no it is not
uh
chapter 18 this one's always a big topic
getting buy-in
napoleon used a technique to obtain
buy-in it was the same technique used by
the union general who commanded the army
of the potomac at gettysburg general
mead mead was a disciple of napoleon the
technique was called a war council on
july 2nd 1863 mead brought his
lieutenants into his makeshift
headquarters at the leicester house he
had an agenda that evening the council
had to provide their recommendations on
one of three courses of action mead
would have to decide
one
the union army should leave the
battlefield two the union army should
stay and fight an offensive battle three
the union army should stay and fight a
defensive battle
mead began by asking his lower ranking
and least experienced lieutenants to
voice their opinions first he used this
method because he knew if the more
senior officers spoke first more junior
officers in terms of rank reputation or
experience might feel too intimidated to
disagree
after all this was by design a
hierarchical organization mead knew he
had to get the lower ranking leaders to
speak first in order to get their
unvarnished thoughts
after everyone spoke mead decided the
union would stay and fight a defensive
battle the rest as they say is history
the union army was victorious and won
the battle and would go on to win the
war although it would take another
bloody two years before the confederate
army laid down their arms
i when when people ask me this question
how do you get people to buy into the
plan i say let them come up with a plan
you don't have to worry about buying
anymore you don't have to worry about it
you came up with it i i'm buying into
your plan and i can do that easily i can
control my own thoughts and if you come
if john comes up with a plan that's
pretty decent i'm cool with it and and
we'll go with it
yeah yeah um you know as a leader i
found you know give the task give the
purpose but don't give the how uh you
know give the what in the why but not
the how
and usually you know those people who
work for us are going to figure out a
better way to do it than we would have
figured out so yeah you know let them
run with it uh
in any organization
usually those people at the grassroots
level have um
they're closer to the problem set
so turn it over to them now yeah you
might have to provide a little bit of
guidance you might have to you know kind
of you know uh
just just adjust one way or the other
but essentially
uh you know giving them the one y and
let them figure out the how is generally
the best way to handle it and i'll get
leaders say well what if my what if my
subordinates come up with a stupid plan
i'll say what's wrong with you if you've
got subordinates that are coming up with
a stupid plan yeah i'll tell you what's
wrong you haven't trained them properly
you haven't given the right mentorship
and guidance you haven't let them come
up with plans before so they could learn
how to plan better so
if they come up with a stupid plan what
do you do you start asking them some
earnest questions about their plan and
kind of it reveals to them what some of
the holes in their plan are and then
they can make adjustments and while
they're making adjustments they're also
learning so the next time you ask them
ask them to come up with a plan it's may
not be a brilliant plan but at least
it's less stupid than the first plan and
you look up in three months or six
months all of a sudden their planning is
outstanding and you look up in a year
and they're probably planning better
than you are because like you said
they're the ones that are closest to the
problem yeah yeah and you know what you
said a little bit earlier i think is
exactly true you know sometimes
you know our followers will come up with
a plan that isn't exactly the way we
would do it but you know i let them run
with it anyway
you know as long as you know it's not
flawed in any way it's just a different
way than i would have thought of doing
it
and and i think that's really where
leaders have to leave their ego at the
door you know to say you know hey this
isn't the way i do it but it's going to
get the job done it's still going to be
cost effective or you know whatever the
case might be
so so let them go forward with it and
it's you know like you said you don't
have to worry about the buying if they
came up with it i go into every meeting
with my subordinates when i was in a
platoon when i was a tasking commander
right now in the business world i walk
into a meeting with my people
my goal is to use their plan that's my
goal i don't want to use whatever i'm
coming up with i want to use theirs and
if you have that goal at the beginning
that's going to lead you to the best
possible place and look like you said if
their plan is
dumb
which which you know you get some people
come up with some dumb plans
occasionally but occasionally some
people come up with some dumb ideas
that's okay ask them some earnest
questions and they're going to see that
their plan is
well the reality of their plan which is
dumb yeah yeah and you know this kind of
leads into the whole you know asking
your followers what their recommendation
is
and you know some some followers are
going to come up with some type of crazy
recommendation that just you just know
for your experience it ain't going to
work
uh but
i think what leaders need to do is then
get back with those followers and
explain to the follower hey this is why
i didn't use your recommendation now
again i'm you know talking about
situations where there's time to have
those conversations you know if you're
in the middle of the fire fight you know
you gotta sometimes hey you know go left
not right whatever but i'm just saying
you know in in most situations
uh where you're asking for
recommendations on some type of
long-term plan you're putting together
somebody comes up with something wet you
know that's really wacko
and you're not going to use it i i do
think you show people the respect by at
least getting back with them and
explaining to them why i'm not going to
use your plan yeah because that's your
that's also your opportunity to teach
them why that plan wasn't good and again
i'll do it by just by saying hey john i
just want to ask you about you know this
this channelized area that you want to
take your patrol through do you think
that's the best approach to the target
going through this valley where there's
elevated positions on both sides that
could be occupied by the enemy and
you'll look at me and say
you know what boss let me get back to
you and you'll come up with a different
plan exactly um
fast forward a little bit
you got a section in here talking about
tactical patience which is a concept
everybody needs and i think it's the
younger you are the more you need to
understand
tactical patients because the younger
you are the less tactile patients you
generally have and that goes all the way
to like little children that are four
years old they have the least amount of
tactical patients so you talk about that
but what i like here is you also throw
in a section that is is uh called what
tactical patients is not
demonstrating tactical patients is not
about putting off a decision
it is about taking the time when you
have the luxury of having time to think
through the information available and
the recommendations before deciding just
as nothing happened in business before
somebody sells something
nothing happens in business until the
leader decides good leaders have to have
the courage to make a decision with less
than perfect information
so it's good to be tactically patient
but also there comes a time where
you got to make a call yeah absolutely
and uh
you know jack welch you know the
ceo at general electric for for 20 years
uh i think from like 81 until 2001
you know he he wrote in one of his books
that the problem he saw with mid-level
managers throughout general electric
is
the the unsuccessful ones were the ones
who did not have the courage to make a
decision
and again when you make a decision
you're putting yourself out there
and and some leaders just don't want to
take that uh you know that risk to put
themselves out there and
and and uh potentially
make the wrong decision but it's so
important because again
once you make a decision it doesn't mean
that you have to stick by that decision
no matter what you know you've got to
assess what's going on
you know get some feedback about what's
actually happening out there you know
the real deal and then you know make
those adjustments as you go but anybody
who thinks that hey once i made this
decision i can't i can't deviate from it
i don't think that's a good technique
yeah and that's a technique that i talk
about in leadership strategy and tactics
book is
i call it iterative decision making i'm
going to make the smallest decisions i
can you know you want me to go
assault a part of the city of ramadi i
say hey got it boss
we're gonna take one building we're
gonna start with this one little
building over here and see how that goes
if like we get a good foothold and now
we can put some troops in a good spot
now i can go to the next building i
don't send you know all my troops in a
bunch of different buildings at the same
time no i'm gonna make small steps in
that direction and and then then it's
very easy for me to make adjustments
it's very easy for me to say oh you know
what hey boston i need more troops or
hey boss this doesn't make sense right
now this is way more fortified than we
thought it was going to be
whatever the case may be i can make
adjustments but i start off by making
very small decisions and then adjusting
and the other thing that that i was
thinking about while you were saying
that is
when you were talking about jack welch
and and the mid-level managers failing
to make decisions because they don't
want to put themselves out out there and
this reminds me of what you were talking
about earlier and what's in the book the
idea of
forming like scar tissue and a habit
if you get in the habit
of saying hey look i made a decision
wasn't the best call
it's on me here's the adjustment we're
gonna make once you realize that that
doesn't it's not the end of the world to
do that
now i can tell you you can you can you
do that to an extent where people don't
think hey chocolate's just nothing but
bad decisions and every decision he
makes goes hey my mistake okay this one
was my mistake hey sorry guys this was
my mistake eventually you're going to
lose some clout and you're going to lose
some credibility you can't just make bad
decisions all the time but if you make
decisions hey
even a what is it a a broken clock is
right twice a day you're gonna be right
some of the times you know if you're
doing a good assessment you make a
decision and it turns out to be wrong
hey guys sorry my fault that we should
have gone a different direction here's
the adjustment we're making people don't
lose respect for you they gain respect
for you but if you don't experience that
and you don't build up the muscle of
making a decision owning the outcome
whether it's good or bad own the outcome
you can build up
a muscle memory for doing that where it
becomes habitual and it's okay and i
think if you never
if you never
step into that arena
you're just scared of it you know it's
like mikey in the dragons other kids
book i wrote the the he the kid's scared
of the dragons he doesn't realize that
the dragons are small and that's true
with most things we fear so if you don't
open that door go in that cave and make
a decision occasionally
you're never going to understand that
there's a once you do that if it was a
bad decision
just own it
make adjustments and move forward
you need to learn that you need to feel
that and you can get used to it yeah and
and you know jacco i was listening to an
interview you were participating in once
and i think you said something to effect
that
every every problem is a leadership
problem
and and you know what that gets to is
you know leaders have to create an
environment where subordinates feel
comfortable taking the risk to make a
decision and know hey if it doesn't turn
out exactly right at least you know i'm
not going to get my legs chopped out
from underneath me so you know it's
really important that
you know if you if if you're a leader
and you see that
you've got
subordinate leaders who are hesitant to
make a decision maybe you should look in
the mirror and think to yourself hey
what am i doing to create an environment
where these these people are afraid to
even even decide or or make a mistake
that's not a good environment a horrible
environment and you're going to end up
your team is going to fail eventually
yeah
um
fast forward a little bit chapter 25
iron sharpens iron
as iron sharpens iron so one person
sharpens another proverbs 27 17.
and this is
right in line with what you were just
talking about
demonstrate initiative an attribute i
felt strongly about was initiative at
every level of leadership throughout the
division
and this is again this is when you were
in a in a leadership position this was a
result of my combat experience in ramadi
iraq i saw during my time in ramadi how
it was essential that junior leaders
demonstrate initiative in order to get
ahead of the decision-making loop of our
enemies
i believed if we did not encourage
initiative in steady-state operations
and training exercise subordinate
leaders would not display the necessary
level of initiative winning combat i put
out written guidance and i continually
reinforce stating i believe
demonstrating high levels of initiative
was worth the risk of making honest
mistakes
so this is exactly what you were just
talking about
if you've got a team that's not making
decisions
you're you're the problem and the way
you
the way you instilled that culture
inside your division when you were a
division commander was by talking about
it by putting out written guidance by
demonstrating it and i like this this
point of the fact that initiative is
worth the risk of making honest mistakes
that's a huge deal if you're a
subordinate leader and you know that the
boss wants you to take initiative and
that it is worth the risk of making
honest mistakes
that's
that could be a game changer for a young
leader yeah you know i think that's an
important statement uh there about you
know
demonstrating initiative is worth the
risk of making honest mistakes but the
caveat to that is is if you're a leader
and you put that statement out there
guess what your subordinates are going
to be looking for they're going to be
looking for the first time somebody
demonstrates initiative and makes an
honest mistake and they're going to
they're going to watch
how do you react to this thing
and um and actually i i think it was my
sergeant major you know chris kepner who
mentioned that to me after i put that
statement out he goes you know people
are going to be watching to see how you
react the first time somebody makes an
honest mistake by demonstrating
initiative and that was a little you
know some good counsel from him so
again leaders again to to develop and
cultivate this trust and organization
they put something out there
now they really have to pay attention to
make sure that they
you know they they walk the talk there
and and and do what they said they're
going to do because people are going to
be watching nobody's going to be leaving
nobody's going to believe that written
word until they actually see an action
uh
fast forward here
you're talking about some of the
internal attributes
it says if leaders cannot get in touch
with their own feelings they will have
difficulty understanding the feelings of
others leaders must practice
self-awareness and mindfulness
once one develops self-awareness and you
talk about i'm fast forward a little bit
you talk about journaling is a good
technique like writing down what your
thoughts what your feelings are so that
you get some perspective on them i'm
going to fast forward a little bit
once one develops self-awareness one can
then become better at controlling
emotions
followers look to leaders to be able to
get things get stable when things get
chaotic controlling one's emotions has
many personal organizational and
societal benefits
i remember when i was young i was a
young inexperienced leader i acted out
in front of a group of my followers
showing great displeasure not with them
but with the situation we were dealing
with i ranted and raved and threw my
notebook across the room as an
inexperienced leader i thought this
would demonstrate to my followers
followers i was all in
instead when i saw the negative reaction
of my followers i realized this was a
poor technique
you remember what happened what made you
so mad yeah it was uh actually i was a
lieutenant on active duty commanding a
platoon and uh i can't remember the
actual incident that made me upset but
it was something that
was upsetting to to our
to our unit the whole platoon got
weekend duty or something like that
something you know and i thought okay
i'm going to show them i really you know
care care about this and
acted out and i realized that they were
they were not looking for a leader to
act like that they were looking for the
leader to act professional and more
stable
and and i think i might have either
wrote in that book or or somewhere else
uh that they were looking for a rock and
instead what they got was a pile of sand
you know
and uh you know that that really taught
me
that
you know it's it's kind of like being a
parent you know kids aren't looking for
friends they're looking for parents you
know and and and subordinates aren't
looking for for buddies they're looking
for followers that they could count on
and it'd be
be a father and and the other thing is i
i like to say is that
leaders don't need to be great all the
time but they need to be great when it
makes a difference they need to be great
when it matters you know because you
know let's face it you know steady state
operations 80 of the time thing 90 of
the time things are kind of moving along
right you know but then you hit this
bump in the road and that's where you
really got to stand up and you got to be
a leader and you've got to show that
that
ability to control your emotions and to
be stable because that
that that is something that creates
confidence into organization if a leader
falls apart like that uh then then
heck the subordinates don't have anybody
to count on because even the leader is
starting to crumble that that's not a
good thing so that happened on early on
that happened early on in my career and
i realized what a mistake that was so i
was always very very
uh cognizant of of the fact that hey
yeah you had a you had to show strength
when things were kind of caving in all
around you that that's what that's what
your supports are expecting i always
looked at it
if my leader couldn't control his
emotions how the heck is he going to be
able to make good decisions and i always
remembered i saw when i was younger some
of the leaders i had would fly off the
handle and i just think well how's this
guy going to make a decision no one
makes a good decision when they're
emotional no
uh displaying empathy empathy is an
essential element of being a servant
leader empathetic leaders can sense what
their followers are feeling this
eliminates tone deafness and the
perception leaders do not understand or
worse yet the perception the leader does
not care
when followers think a leader does not
care they will stop bringing forth their
problems and issues
empathy is the capacity to show
followers you care about them a leader
must understand how followers feel
and what their issues are in order to
provide their resources allowing
followers to do their job more
effectively and increase the probability
of mission accomplishment
you want to see the perspective of the
people on your team
and you know i think it was colin powell
who said something to the fact that when
when
soldiers stop bringing you their
problems you've effectively stopped
being a leader and you know you could
apply that to you know civilian sector
as well when you're the people who work
for you stop bringing you problems you
you've really
effectively lost your ability to to lead
them because
you know folks are going to stop
bringing us their problems when they
figure either
um you can't do anything about it
or you just don't care enough to do
anything about it
um and and and that's
just a terrible position for for a
leader to be in
yeah you gotta you gotta maintain that
connection as always a running joke
whenever i'm in a leadership position
that no one ever tells me that they're
tired that they don't wanna work more it
just never happens right so i always
have to make sure that i'm pulling that
string a little bit more than normal
because no one wants to come and say hey
jonker we've had enough we want to do
don't want to do another operation we
don't want to go we've been on the road
too no one ever wants to tell me that so
i always have to make sure i'm digging a
little bit deeper otherwise they won't
say a damn thing
uh section three is resilience
and i'm gonna read a little section here
um
our four up honored up armored humvees
launched themselves out of the gate of
ford operating base ramadi on a sun
drenched sunday morning in september
2005 the heat was stifling the euphrates
river running through our area added a
high degree of humidity causing my eye
protection to mess up with sweat we were
traveling around around along route
michigan toward observation post hotel
overlooking east ramadi op hotel a
suicide bomber attacked the observation
post a few weeks earlier but failed to
dislodge the tenacious soldiers who
operated out of there i wanted to check
on the soldiers and gauge their morale
our vehicles made their way through the
city
through a city struggling due to the
violent insurgency there still as we
made our way east
toward east ramadi the streets were busy
with vehicle and pedestrian traffic i
was happy to have my brigade chaplain
riding along with me in the back seat of
our vehicle in the army i have always
been a big fan of our chaplains these
warriors of a higher power could bolster
the spirit of soldiers anytime they
visited a unit the chaplain was also
part of my personal staff and i valued
their insight prior to making a decision
affecting the welfare of soldiers
after our visit to op hotel we made our
bat our way back through the center of
the city the chaplain noticed the same
thing i and every soldier in our mounted
patrol noticed
the vehicles and pedestrians covering
the streets about two hours earlier had
disappeared
there was a strange quietness clothing
the neighborhood we were passing through
we had seen this before
we braced ourselves for an insurgent
attack
we all became a bit tense as our senses
were alerted
the banter we usually engaged in as we
moved about the city was quieted as we
gave the alleys and buildings around us
our full attention
in order to calm down our crew the
chaplain announced in a loud voice
fear not boys god is with us
the young specialist operating out of
the gunners compartment of our vehicle
heard the chaplain's announcement and
from his more exposed position atop the
vehicle he playfully called down to the
chaplain god may be with you all down
there but he certainly is not up here
with me
about 20 seconds later we heard the boom
of a rocket-propelled grenade
the grenade squarely hit the armor
shield
surrounding our young gunner
and harmlessly ricocheted into the air
before exploding and causing no harm to
personnel and no damage to equipment
our stunned gunner did not miss a beat
he quickly and loudly proclaimed i stand
corrected chaplin god just arrived
of course we all broke up with laughter
it was good having the chaplain with us
that day and this is a section that
you've got called spiritual fitness
talk to us about spiritual fitness yeah
you know um
you know when we talk about fitness of
course you know we think of physical
fitness and you know mental fitness
emotional fitness but i think spiritual
fitness is a big part of helping us
develop our leadership strength
and that's whether we
are part of some type of formal you know
religion or whether we just uh are
connected
to our spirituality in another way you
know through nature through meditation
whatever the case
it's it's important that we understand
that there's something
i this my own personal beliefs there's
something larger going on in the
universe around us it's not all about us
you know we're just just we're just a
speck of everything that's going on and
i think that helps us keep grounded i
think it keeps it helps us keep humble
and and i think it again kind of aligns
with whatever values we say are our
personal values where it will help us
uh stay on the right track
as as we're making these these decisions
so i think if if leaders don't take the
time to reflect on
uh the the notion that there's
a higher power out there that there's
something going on that's really much
bigger than ourselves
they may be missing something
and this that that's one part of this
whole section of the book which is
called resilience and this is one of
your three overall themes
and you've got some other facets of
resilience in here
positive energy
and that's an overused statement right
and and what i was thinking about what i
was reading this is
you know you can think of the positive
energy as someone that's sort of like
it's it's hard to understand or it can
be hard to understand
but if you think of people that have
negative energy it's real easy to
understand those people right it's
really easy someone is oh this is never
gonna work oh we're screwed all this is
horrible you we all know people like
that and it seems easier to identify
maybe i shouldn't use the word hard to
understand it can be hard to under hard
to identify someone that has positive
energy it's really easy to to there's
more people it seems that have negative
energy and occasionally you'll get
someone that's just got super positive
and and then you'll remember that and
you'll remember
how their you know what their response
was when something was going wrong and
how they took it and they look around
like oh good we get another chance to go
at this or whatever the case may be so i
think that's that's a good one you got
fitness physical fitness in here yeah
which is again something that um
i get
often asked
does that come from the military or is
that just part of you and the answer is
look there's plenty of people in the
military that get out of the military
and physical fitness their physical
fitness
fails yeah and they get out of shape so
it's not something that you get it's not
a chip you get programmed
you need to work at it yeah yeah and
just getting back to your your uh piece
there about the positive energy you know
you mentioned those negative people i
like to call them energy sponges because
they just kind of sap the energy from
everyone around them it's kind of like
why do i want to be around this person
man you know uh
and uh
it's it's just not good for a leader to
be that way uh i like to say a leader
should brighten up the room when they
enter it not when they leave it you know
if you're the type of leader that
brightens up a room when you when you
leave it it's kind of like man you're
doing you're doing something wrong there
so
uh again it's not like you got to be you
know all smiling and slapping people on
the back and glad-handing people all the
time but but people have to know that
you're expecting tomorrow to be a better
day than today and who doesn't want to
be around a leader who believes that
tomorrow is going to be better than
today you know because you know we want
to move forward and
and that's what i mean by by positive
energy and like we talked about earlier
in the podcast here
uh
you have to have an action plan a
believable action plan
you know if you want to be known as as a
as a positive leader because people
aren't going to
to follow you if they just think you're
glad handing everything and you really
don't have a plan to back it up that's
important yeah you got to you got to see
a pathway to get this mission done yeah
and see a way to get out of this
miserable situation that we're in and
see a way to have some fun with it yeah
yeah i mean hey you know it's human
nature people want to be able to you
know have people want to be able to
enjoy their work you know and uh if you
know the old saying you know if you
enjoy your work you're not going to work
a day in your life and i truly believe
that and you and and again you just got
to find those things that really you
know keep you motivated keep you excited
about life what about vulnerability this
is another thing that you clue into here
um
talk to us about vulnerability from a
leadership perspective yeah when i when
i talk about vulnerability uh and we
already talked a little bit about the
first part it's about
uh having the courage to leave your
comfort zone allowing yourself to be
vulnerable to try
something maybe you haven't tried before
or something that's a little bit hard
but the other
aspects
of
vulnerability
is
putting yourself out there and exposing
yourself to your followers and i'll i'll
tell you what i mean by that one way to
expose yourself to your followers and i
i think this is a helpful technique
is
sharing stories with your followers
about times maybe when you tried
something and you failed you know or or
you made a mistake
and uh
the reason i think that's important is
because you know followers look at at a
leader to think man they're in this
position of leadership everything they
touched in life must you know must have
turned a goal they probably never made
any mistakes so they want to be in this
position of leadership and we know
nothing could be farther from the truth
so by
by explaining to your followers how hey
you know i've i've tried and i've failed
sometimes and i've made mistakes and
this is how is it able to overcome these
mistakes that that inspires uh those
followers and then the other piece about
vulnerability
is having the humility to ask people on
your team and i know you've written
about this because i've read it
but have the humility to ask people on
your team
what they think and how they would do
something and then
having the humility to follow through
with their recommendation when you see
it's a good recommendation that should
be followed and and again not just
having that attitude that hey i'm the
leader you've only got two years on the
job what could you possibly know you
know more more than i i know uh but
again you don't know what life
experience that person had so so asking
people their opinion we talk about
respect i think one of the best ways you
could show somebody on your team that
you respect them is by asking their
opinion
could you imagine working for somebody
for 10 years
and you've never had that person you
worked for ever ask you for your opinion
i mean
you know
how could that make you feel good and
and how could that make you feel that
that leader of yours respects you man
you never even asked me what i thought
you know so i think one of the best ways
to show people you respect them is to
ask their opinion doesn't mean you have
to follow their recommendation like we
mentioned earlier and if you don't
follow their recommendation a good
technique is getting back with them and
explain to them why
uh but i think uh to me that's what
vulnerability is is all about those
couple of things there
yeah this is another negative example
that i think is easier to see
is if you're talking if you work for me
and you're talking and i cut you off
right that's everyone knows that's
disrespectful
well it's that also means that if i
actually listen to what you have to say
that i'm being respectful i'm giving you
respect so that's a if you can't
remember to listen to people remember
how rude it is when someone cuts you off
and the opposite of that is to actually
listen to people here's another i think
this is a
a vulnerability that is so uncomfortable
for leaders and people and subordinates
up and down the chain of command it's a
vulnerability that is
that is
people avoid almost at all costs
and that is the ability to say
i don't know
yeah i don't hey i don't know
hey what do you think we should do this
i don't know up and down the chain of
command
i think the first the first place i
learned this when when i got to the seal
teams you didn't get your you weren't a
seal when you got to the seal teams you
were a new guy
uh an fng as a matter of fact so you get
there you're an fng you don't have your
trident which is the insignia that means
you're a seal and so you have to study
for six months you're on a probationary
board you have to
you're on probation i should say and
then you have to eventually go in front
of a verbal board and you go to the
diving you go to the weapons you go to
parachute you go to tactics you go to
the radios you and all these chiefs and
master chiefs and senior chiefs and
they're asking you questions and what
they tell you isn't this is this is
probably the first place i realized okay
well that's that's the right thing to do
if they ask you a question and you don't
know
what you say is
i don't know let me do some research and
i'll get back to you
and that's the right answer and they're
going to ask you some questions they're
going to dig so deep into those manuals
they're going to get that answer or you
can sit there and say you can try and
make up an answer you can try and
pretend like you know it and then you're
going to get crushed because you lack
the humility and you're not being
vulnerable enough to say hey
i actually don't know so up and down the
chain of command just like you said no
one expects
the leader to know everything
as a leader we think everyone expects us
to know everything and when we try and
act like that we look like idiots yeah
you don't know everything
just say hey i don't know
what do you think it's perfectly fine
three powerful words there that leaders
should live by
when they don't know
say it
uh skipping forward a little bit
remaining calm during the storm
you you talk about some ways to do this
and you got a couple points in here take
control over the things you can i think
this is something that even though it's
so obvious
we still fail to do that as people we
worry about things we have no control
over
so don't do that but you got another
another section in here
do not
catastrophize now did you make up that
word no that's actually a word i heard
when i went through resiliency training
okay they talked about the concept of
catastrophizing so here's the section on
catastrophizing the united states army
trains soldiers on techniques that will
help them display resiliency one of
those techniques which i think is
particularly relevant during these
uncertain times is how to not
catastrophize
when you catastrophize you focus only on
the worst case scenario you believe the
worst will happen and of course this
produces a great deal of anxiety this
can also sow the seeds of a
self-fulfilling prophecy
a method to place things
in perspective and avoid catastrophizing
is by going through a practical thought
process promoting resiliency and
reducing anxiety
first look at what the worst case
scenario would possibly look like second
identify what the best case scenario
might be third consider the most likely
or probable outcome then focus your
attention on the plan on the most
probable case and develop your primary
plan of action around that scenario so
this is something i think the reason i
got a little bit focused on this
is because this is what our news media
gets paid to do catastrophize everything
yeah everything is catastrophized
everything is a worst case scenario the
world's gonna have i if you follow the
headlines the world ends every single
day it gets killed by kovid by war by
this politician by that politician every
single day there's a catastrophe that
happens
and and if you do that as a leader
you nee you're making a mistake but but
what's also important is
you can't react to these things and
someone runs into the office with some
massive problem it's like okay let's
think through it okay i see you're
excited awesome let's think through it
catastrophizing
you know i'm surprised uh i woke up this
morning you know
watching the news i thought the world
ended yesterday
uh but but yeah you're you're exactly
right and and i do try to use this
technique uh
because usually the very worst case
doesn't doesn't happen and and you get
yourself all spun up about it all
friggin tense and and stressed out about
and it's not going to do you any good
anyway um this is uh
one of one of the most beautiful things
i learned in the military
is the is the counter to the
catastrophizing individual above you in
the chain of command below you in the
chain of command appear whatever they
they're panicking they're freaking out
and what you learn in the military you
learn this powerful word which is roger
that or either roger or roger that
someone comes in they're going crazy
like oh you gotta believe this happened
i'd be like roger
meaning okay i understand let's let's
think about it so
any time be very careful as a leader be
very careful with the words you choose
to to explain what's happening
and and sometimes as a leader
we want to get a reaction out of people
where we've got this situation happening
and we know it's critical and we need to
make some adjustments and so in order to
get people moving instead of explaining
to them
what's happening and why we need to make
a move we just go straight to level 12
catastrophize right in order to get it
in order to get people to move we
catastrophize
and the problem with that is it ends up
being the little boy that cried wolf
where you catastrophize everything
everything's a catastrophe everything's
gonna end the world everything's a
strategic failure for the team
everything's a catastrophic event and
it's like no
in fact there are so few catastrophic
events that can actually happen
that there's almost nothing
that you can catastrophize with me
you're gonna get through just about
everything that's kind of like the whole
thing if everything's a priority
nothing's a priority exactly you know
you've you've really got to be clear
about what the priorities are
and then get everybody working toward
achieving those you know probably maybe
two or three priorities so things that
are really important
prioritize and execute i believe i
believe that's the word um
hey i want to close out with one last uh
section here
um
and it's it's how you close out the book
but it's it's a good indicator of
everything else that's in the book
so it says this i was raised by my
father to have faith in god
though we though my father faced
setbacks such as losing his wife at an
early age and raising seven children
after her death he never lost faith
my father made it a point to march us
march all seven of his children
into church every sunday morning
this made a lifelong impression not only
on me and my siblings
but many others who resided in our
community
there are certain things i learned about
good leadership as a young boy from my
father and others that have been
reinforced throughout my life the things
i learned were the importance of having
strong character and staying true to
your values even when things got tough
being service oriented and helping
other people whenever you could
regardless of their race religion
and setting an example by doing the
right thing even when no one was
watching
i know i am not a perfect leader but i
continue to do my best to learn how i
can become a better person and a better
leader and i encourage all who read this
book to do the same
seek to place the organization you lead
in good hands
well
i think that's what we're all trying to
do we're all trying to
do the same thing continue to learn
um
continue to try and become better people
and better leaders and definitely
appreciate you for writing this book
and and giving some of these lessons
learned
no jocko i appreciate the um the time to
talk about it
i appreciate the time to uh
talk about the book with you and just uh
really
grateful that we could spend a little
bit of time you and i just just talking
about our own leadership philosophies
and
and uh what it means to continue to to
learn and continue to grow to be a
better leader so thank you for the
opportunity
yeah there's i mean obviously we use
some different verbiage and some focus
here and there might be a little bit
different but the underlying themes
i mean these are these are what
leadership these these are the
underlying themes that exist in
leadership anywhere you look anybody
that understands it
is gonna you're gonna see these common
themes um so right now
you've got
a consulting company called leader
grover's at leaders grove leader leader
growth leader grove and it's
leadergrove.com yes um you got
johngronsky.com
people can find you there you're on
twitter at jlgronski
[Music]
you're on youtube
youtube channel that's john gronski yeah
linkedin john gronski there's a good
thing about having the last name gronsky
it's not a real common last name
it's like mine the last name not correct
not not real comment yeah so you can you
can get away with it and and you can
just call everything gronsky um
linkedin john gronski and then you got
facebook which is john gronski leeds
and uh what else oh the gram oh you're
on the gram yeah you're on the ground
see
echo charles you know what's up yeah and
that and that's that john gronski leads
on the ground
uh
so
any any other echo you got anything no
sir i think we covered it
that's it huh nothing from mac oh it was
interesting to see the the
i mean not necessarily the contrast but
the overlap so much overlapping you know
different terminology how you said but
very interesting yeah yeah it's um good
leadership good leadership across the
board
any closing comments the only closing
comment i have
is that i've got a
i've got a good time drinking your jocko
go uh energy drink so i love that mango
yeah that that's echo's favorite flavor
as well but i just want to thank you
again for the message you put out i mean
you put out a message that uh
so many uh
people could follow whether they're in a
leadership position or not and by the
way i think everybody is in some
position of leadership uh and and i
think you agree with me when i say you
don't have to be in a formal position of
leadership in order to lead but anyway
thank you for putting the message out
you do
and and to the kids too you know what
your your kids um uh you know the books
you put out for for children to help
them get on the right path
uh is very important so
appreciate that the other thing i want
to thank you for is uh you know getting
a picture myself
you
echo together so when people look at the
picture they could see what a a small
unmessed unmuscular man i really am
compared to you two so i appreciate that
but no really jocko uh thanks for having
me back again and and again thanks for
the leadership message that you continue
to get out there so i appreciate that i
i always say um if you interact with
other human beings you're in a
leadership position
so if if you're listening to this right
now you're in a leadership position hey
thanks thanks for writing the book
that's going to help people lead and
more important once again thanks for
your service thanks for your service in
the army national guard the army and the
national guard
and
thanks once again to you and to your
soldiers
and the the service and sacrifice and
the battle of ramadi um the efforts that
your guys put forth they they literally
saved my guys lives we learned lessons
from you when we got on the ground we
listened to what you had to say you told
us to do operations you told us not to
do other operations you told us to stay
off this street you told us how to
better do our tactics
so your guys
from the 228
literally saved the lives of my guys i
know it and uh we will never forget what
you and your men did for us and and did
for america
thanks jocko thanks for coming on
and with that
general john gronski has left the
building
so echo yes kind of close that out
talking about how people
we all
want to be better need to be better can
be better
it's true where do we start well we
start with our health
without health we have nothing
straight up from what i understand you
had a little disregard of your health
the other day and went to a
mcdonald's restaurant it was uh i ate
food it was a momentary lapse of
judgment and discipline and discipline
for sure but it's the it was it was very
did you break
um
opportunistic and this is the kind of
stuff we got to be careful
for or about or whatever
you know how you have a routine
and every once in a while get reminded
of the importance of a routine okay all
right i'm not a i don't 100 sign on to
the whole routine this mcdonald's party
but it's an example if you don't have a
routine
what it does is create little
opportunities
okay this part is nothing new if you
have a routine it's like okay you don't
you don't have opportunities
it doesn't doesn't matter okay i bought
i got the the item that is a soft soft
bun
and inside that bun is a fish flavored
concoction you got the fish fillet yeah
yeah i don't think that's there's a real
fish in there at all but either way do
you think there's like a
crayfish or something in there
you know you know what it is it's like
one of those are just pure sugar yeah
it's like a cinnamon synthetic they they
do
i don't know but this is what it feels
like maybe like a synthetic material
that's made
maybe you know like a 3d printer or
something like this with like some some
stuff
and then they put like some fish like
extract flavor in it and then fry it
okay
was that the path is that the path is
just making you better okay okay okay
the path is kind of a routine it
essentially is and this importance of
the routine where if you have a routine
there's way way way less opportunity to
make to have like oh like a
decision-making conundrum right because
the routine the decision you have
already made before it's part of the
routine well you're not hangry hey go
through emotional departure depression
because you haven't had a freaking
fish sammy a few hours either way if
you're hangry even you already know
because dinner's soon or you know when
the dinner is see i'm saying if you have
a routine or lunch or breakfast whatever
you can you're about to eat whatever
comes in with these big shoes ready to
take you off the bath here's here's what
ronald does he just waits he waits for
the people with no routine or or he'll
slide into your routine but a lot of
times for people like me in this case
where
the little the little crack in the
routine
he's right there he's like hey you need
a decision to make i'll make it easy for
you what's the one that's going to give
you the payoff the quickest you see him
saying that's what it was instead of
going home to dinner my wife was
somewhere else and she was like hey you
know like you know i don't know how much
food there's going to be here or
whatever so you know grab something this
was like cool i made the turn in like
literally on my way home changed
trade trajectory [__] took the uh
exit and boom mcdonald's was right there
made it happen
in a bad way all right so we don't want
to consume things that are are horrible
no what do we want to do the point is
health health is something with no
health look if i'm going to mcdonald's
every single day my health goes down
down down and then eventually i become
incapable of pretty much anything
so if you're unhealthy or your health is
in decline or whatever by your own
meanwhile you have if you have control
over it and you choose to not be healthy
you can have some problems okay so let's
choose to be healthy that's what i think
i like it so on this path starts with
health
fitness capability uh mental and
physical now with that
we can have little helpers on the way
that helper is choco fuel
so i'm actually working on a video
charcoal fuel video cool just a small
one about why you jocko
started choco fuel interesting
it actually doesn't go very deep when
you think about it it's like the stuff
that you were using anyway that's one of
the worst hype you know things i've ever
heard i think i'm so not hyped for this
video right now yeah but here's the only
reason i'm a little bit hyped is i know
you wouldn't bring it up unless you are
hyped so you must have some vision
about some explosions that are going to
happen uh yeah you know potentially i
mean maybe may not have explosions
either way the point is though the point
is
the reason jocko started jocko fuel is
stuff that you use anyway yeah
so you figure okay let me just refine
and and maximize
the quality on these things that i use
anyway produce them
boom and then we'll have that product
there you go one of the many little
helpers in life helpers on the path
because let's face it you're it's late
you dinner chance dinner plans change
you're hungry
you you could easily go to mcdonald's
like echo charles did which is taking
him in the wrong direction off the path
unhealthy feeling sick later
not doing a good workout the next day
just everything is turning bad or you
could power and be like oh cool i got
milk at home yep i got mulk at home
very high it's a savior yeah it is true
and and i'll even explain it's the same
how much of a savior it is so look okay
so energy drinks right mm-hmm we all
know that we're like hey i had to get
the enough sleep or dang i have a huge
workload today and tomorrow
maybe i needed a little boost or maybe
i'm just used to a little boost at some
point in the day right but usually we've
got to pay a price
either we crash or either we're drinking
something that's unhealthy boom these
energy drinks go
jocko discipline go may or may not be
called discipline anymore it's called
this fungal all right there you go boom
jacob this lingo is an energy drink with
front side and backside benefits
and no downside no downside we kind of
went off on that recently we're talking
just this is the no downside piece yeah
most things that are as gratifying and
have so much upside usually yeah well
there's always a little downside right
no downside not this time boom little
helper on that path and me you're on the
path you're still on the path literally
in fact you're even more
down the path yeah in a good way
totally positive across the board so
boom or you get home let's face it every
once in a while you eat dinner you had a
good day you had a good week great week
spent time with the family got your work
done you know you're you're you moved
ahead
you just want a little celebratory
dessert something like this even the
weird thing is even after you have
a 26 ounce rib eye steak
sure
and it's
perfectly cooked
even after you get done with that you're
you're totally good to go
but there's another little part of your
brain
that wants something called dessert oh
yeah and you could just be like oh well
where's the cheesecake or whatever oh
yeah and kind of negate a lot of the the
stuff that you've been doing all week
working hard with yeah
we made you dessert yep garmu so we got
some mold boom and here look you wanna
moc is good let's say you're tired it's
a hard week just add the milk to the
milk or the whatever your your
preferred mixer this is not a
challenging
recipe exactly directive yeah but not
limited to
that simplicity add some stuff in there
i had a half a banana that's me that's
my jam
right there do what you will it's the
same deal this will not
have you slip off the path you're still
in the path
and all of this is a really long way of
saying go to jugglefield.com get
yourself some stuff get yourself some
joint warfare krill oil super krill
um
vitamin d3
cold war yeah these are all helpers with
all
[Music]
just a b testing things to make it taste
good they don't care they don't care
what you feel like and they don't care
about your health yeah don't care
there's not one single person advocating
for your health no they're advocating
for your wallet
don't do it
isn't that because you know how you just
said that like almost with like a like a
i don't see like a joking tone right
yeah but but it's not scary part is that
is 100 true where it's there is not one
single person one single person
interested in the success of that
business which is not necessarily a
wrong thing to be interested in success
of your business well it's wrong if
you're going to sacrifice people's
health
not one person cares about your health
in fact your health is kind of like a
pawn in their big game at jocko fuel
your health is paramount that's the only
otherwise we wouldn't do
we we waited like an extra six months
and built out the line to pasteurize the
the the jocko go so that we didn't have
to put chemicals in it to keep it
preserved yeah
that's that's that shows you your health
is paramount oh yeah
otherwise we hey you know it's not that
big everybody else uses these chemicals
no
don't matter
yeah isn't that kind of scary when you
put it into perspective not once it's
like you know what the most important
thing about you is your wall you know
what i'm gonna use that as a pawn in my
business savages that's insane oh that's
scary
nonetheless jockofield.com boom energy
drinking wah wah you can get go at wawa
you get everything at vitamin shop too
go and hook that up it's true
also origin usa american-made stuff this
is good stuff by the way so you get your
american-made denim
some leather on there jiu-jitsu stuff
geez rash guards um some some fitness
a tire
they're they're hoodies so i got a new
one and i had the old ones from before
which is fine but when you wear them
every
other day
they kind of you know they get worn out
and get used to them and you're like
cool but i went to the camp i got a new
one i was like
that's a nice one um they have a new uh
heavy hoodie too
it's legit yeah
called the heavy yeah
we all know what that's from nonetheless
all the materials that are that make
these the heavies what a freaking epic
epic
freaking moment in life yeah pete does a
good job with those names those creative
names and stuff the heavy yeah
but yeah so even the materials that they
make these things with our mage and
grown in america so keep that in mind
originusa.com
also
jocko has a store it's called jocko
store
this is where you can get your
discipline equals freedom t-shirts
hoodies hats whichever way you want to
represent on this path
it's not an easy path but it's worth it
as a wise man once said if you want to
represent
boomjocklestore.com also we have a thing
called the short locker this is where
you can get a new shirt with cool
designs is that sure you're wearing
sherlock or shirt yes sir okay sure now
something i have to say it's cool all
right i even got jocko signed on to that
one but yeah there's some cool i would
say it's a pretty much of a pretty much
successful as far as accepted designs
people like them
i'm gonna agree yeah yeah so yeah i'm
gonna again jocklestor.com that's where
you can get all the stuff you like if
you'd like something was the the wolf
shirt yes the shirt locker shirt
so these are approved like highly
approved highly approved desired even
desired yeah for sure
um we uh
we are opening a thing for a member like
some of the members are like hey what
about that one i signed up two months
ago but i kind of want that shirt from
six months ago or four months ago
whatever
so we're opening up the the store for
the members as well so they can they can
add us add a password if they want yeah
so be on the lookout for that one
dang that's awful nice of you
yeah man i'm trying to be accommodating
to the people
uh subscribe to this podcast wherever
you subscribe to podcast we also have
jocko unraveling with daryl cooper and
daryl cooper's been on a mission lately
so we haven't released one in a bit but
we got a ton of topics to talk about so
check out jocko unraveling with myself
and daryl cooper
we got the grounded podcast we got the
warrior kid podcast
we also have the jocko underground
podcast
and that's um
well it's sort of a little bastion of
freedom that we have that we're kind of
setting aside it's our it's our
contingency
ao area of operations look if people get
crazy with this whole platform the
platforms and there's a bunch of them
you figure hey well you know you got
this platform and that platform what are
the chances that they all decide to
either
start inserting ads or start making
people pay or whatever they're gonna do
i don't know
but if it happens we have our own little
our own little world carved out
we appreciate you
coming into our world it's called jock
underground
go to jockowunderground.com if you want
to join if you want to support it cost
eight dollars and 18 cents a month
and that's how we're paying to build
this alternative platform
and that way we don't have to
read ads
from some freaking
whatever
apple company or
banana
outfit i don't know
[Music]
if you can't afford it that's cool we
still want you in the game email
assistance at jacquelineground.com we
appreciate the support and we also have
a youtube channel
speaking of platforms it's true
where we put up videos
yep so far youtube pretty
straightforward towards the platform you
know videos we've gotten demonetized a
couple times yeah we've had warnings
only a couple times like what is the the
warning of info
yeah and keep in mind when you say
demonetized because there's a difference
there's different levels of
demonetization you can get a video to
monetize you can get the uh or the whole
channel
straight up demonetized
or there's somewhere in between where
it's like okay you can proclaim that hey
this video contains some heavy stuff bro
i had um
one halloween i did like a quick video
of working out or whatever or something
and i put in the background halloween
the song by the misfits uh yeah yeah and
we almost instantly it was
whatever blocked banned and whatever
else because it was copyrighted material
i was like bro you know spreading the
word on the misfits like you know what i
mean yeah it's true but they were on
that yeah and you know they did they
they kind of consider both sides i think
anyway because it's like hey what if um
they assume that you're making money off
of your
your probably your video
this is a post oh not on youtube it was
on something else it was on the gram oh
yeah yeah that's different it's weird
they came at me well you know what what
it is
it's my hypothesis i think danzig and
the misfits highly protect their
i would ip yeah because you're you're
essentially acting as a distributor yeah
essentially i all i meant to do is
actually spread the word hey man this is
a great band yeah the misfits bro this
is iconic band yes iconic it's true but
the rules gotta kind of apply to
everybody you know so without some kind
of approval uh distributor um process i
saw the misfits recently
with the chromebacks
like before covid in la in a big giant
stadium and you know what it was
freaking outstanding i mean the crow
mags were awesome yes absolutely harley
was rocking and then the misfits came
out and i was like this is i salute
these guys
that's why you're spreading the word and
then yeah i was trying to spread the
word a little bit and like they thought
i was trying to jack their stuff well in
their defense they didn't see your post
and and was like hey jocko take that
down i don't want you you know
distributing myself that's not how it
went down but wouldn't some people be
like hey can you put a clip out of our
music so more people buy our music right
yeah that could happen right
what wouldn't they think of it that way
instead of the other one technically the
misfits didn't do it directly
technically instagram did it misfits
probably signed up signed that song up
to be monitored or whatever
automatically so without them checking
back with you specifically
or arbitrarily glenn danzig and the
misfits i was
not doing it nefariously i was actually
doing a promotional way if you ever want
to license your songs to me yeah i'll
throw them out there into the world you
can uh
you probably never even heard a misfit
song
which is kind of sad
no i've never i don't think i've heard a
misfit song but i heard you
talk about the message right so kind of
the same thing but that's if you heard a
misfit song you'd probably be like
pretty good yeah oh yeah
it's
it's iconic music to be honest with you
it's iconic music
it's iconic an opinion or a factual
standard factual
um so you can have the misfits what's
called the white list they can white
list your channel
actually this is on youtube i know you
can do this on youtube so because this
is something they say hey it's called
jacqueline's jackass down they can't
whatever the he posts all good as far as
our account goes if they do that with us
i won't abuse it i'm not gonna make like
you know what i mean this is only on
youtube right away on youtube but maybe
we'll do it on instagram
yeah just apply the youtube rule to
instagram yeah i don't know i don't know
i should talk next time see how long it
takes them to shut me down i did some
other old older hardcore bands and that
that just were around for a short period
of time no one ever said anything
so i think it depends on the band
yeah they have to you have to register
your your songs and stuff like even on
youtube like if if if i use a i don't
know your other favorite band like if i
use like taylor swift or something like
this right
you know that all taylor swift songs
have been registered with youtube
through some process that's like hey if
this little thing this little print
imprint or whatever however they monitor
it
turns up
automatic either and they choose whether
it's shut down
blocked or um just silence something
some videos will just be silent because
like hey that audio is not not cool or
they'll just take the monetization did
they demonetize my guitar uh playing
when i played a song by the white
buffalo no no interesting not yours but
when he was on popped right off oh yeah
interesting um so you know it makes
sense it's a process i got a new jam
coming
all right got a new song i'm prepping
cool i'm gonna record it
right on uh so subscribe to that youtube
channel jacob podcast also we got origin
usa if you want to find out what's going
on in america oh their youtube channel
yes yeah there's their origin usa it's
cool to track what's going on up there
see see it feel it be a part of it
yeah it's true check
also what do we got uh
also psychological warfare that's a an
album with tracks that we have not
put
whatever
thing to restrict it because people have
jacked it and use it for all kinds of
things
so but if you want to like uh be a good
human and you want to listen to the
psychological warfare album that has
tracks of me telling you not to freaking
go to mcdonald's not to order a fish
filet mig sandwich
then you can do that go to go to
whatever mp3
thing and you can you can buy
psychological warfare and i'll be on
your phone
waiting to tell you stop
also flipside canvas flipsidecanvas.com
dakota meyer he's got a
company here in america american made
making cool stuff to hang on your wall
and of course it's dakota meyer
even if you just had something dakota
dakota meyer could take a white piece of
paper yeah
and
be like hey i made this i'd be that cool
let's hang it on my wall because that's
the coat of meyer like a little hangman
game he can really
let's put it on the wall yeah yeah i'm
down i agree um
got some books the book that i covered
today was iron sharpened leadership by
john gronski it will be on
our website you can click through there
yes
and then you then you then you'll be
supporting the podcast while you buy a
book you can buy whatever you want once
you click through there through amazon
or whatever it's true
uh final spin book coming out
i wrote this book not it's not a book
about leadership it's a book about
brotherhood it's a book about sacrifice
and it's a book about
corn dogs
gallon jugs of
mayonnaise salmon pie
and buick century wagons
that's what the book's about
no one can explain this book no one
i can't even explain it as you can see i
just tried hey if you want to check out
this new book i got it's called final
spin it's a book it's a poem it's a
transcript
we don't even know what it is
but
so far
we have an audience of one deb the audio
engineer who listened to me read the
audiobook and she quote
loved it
she laughed she cheered she cried that's
what we're talking about uh also
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual the code the evaluation the
protocol dysfunctional freedom field
manual
way the warrior kid one two three and
four mikey and the dragons about face
and extreme ownership and the dichotomy
of leadership a bunch of books i've
written
or
co-written we have a company called
echelon front where we solve problems
through leadership go to
ashlandfront.com if you want help inside
your organization this is also where you
can find details for our live events
including the muster including field
training exercises and ef battlefield
talked a little bit about gettysburg
today the battle of gettysburg you can
come to gettysburg with us
and we will talk through the leadership
challenges that they faced and decisions
that that got made good and bad next
muster is in las vegas october 28th and
29th
next ftx
is september
20th and 21st i think we already passed
that so sorry
keep your eyes open
we also have an online training program
extreme ownership academy it is online
leadership training that you can go to
you don't get good at leadership by
listening to one podcast or by reading
one book you've got to work out in the
leadership gym the leadership gym is
extremeownership.com
go check it out and if you want to help
service members active and retired their
families gold star families check out
mark lee's mom mama lee she's got a
charity organization if you want to
donate or you want to get involved in
that go to america's mightywarriors.org
and if you want
more of me regurgitating reading
or you need more of echo's uncanny quips
you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter
on the gram
and on facebook echoes addict with
charles hi matthew willock
general gronsky general john groncki
john gronski.com
leaders
leadergrove.com
twitter j l gronsky youtube john gronski
linkedin john gronski facebook and the
gram
at john gronski leeds and thanks again
to
general gronsky for joining us special
thanks to all the men and women from the
that served in ramadi iraq in 2005 2006
we only overlapped with you all for
about a month but we appreciate the what
you did there and the turnover that you
got that you gave to us as i mentioned
to general gronsky
you all 100
kept my guys alive from the lessons that
you passed on to us
and we appreciate it from the time we
were working after you left with the 1-1
ad so thanks to all of you and the rest
of the military out there serving right
now
thank you for taking the watch now that
we are done
and the police law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emt's
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol secret service and all first
responders
thanks to all of you for standing on the
watch here at home and to everyone else
out there
here's a little here's a little action
you can take you need a plan
a plan to live by a code a set of
principles values a protocol for
behavior if you don't have that if
you're just don't have that you're just
wandering around
i wrote about it with dave burke and
sarah armstrong in the book the code the
protocol the evaluation i wrote about it
first in the warrior kid books
come up with a code the marine corps
falls a code the rangers follow code the
seals and the army and the samurai and
the knights and the vikings all followed
a code don't wander around get on the
path follow the code and keep getting
after it
and until next time
this is echo and jocko
out